pulled up to Calabasas Ready for War I
might turn to a Savage I just showed up
with the crew the baddest you just
showed up like you might need some
practice uh you going down for the count
it's going down tonight I do it all for
my family you do it all for the likes I
hear that Bell and I'm ready to fight
Turn Me Up Turn Me Up Turn Me Up they
want the Bel they don't work up don't
mess around end up hurting them I say
the wrong thing make it personal you say
the wrong thing I might hurt them
popping fam welcome in Cal fight
companion for UFC
296 it's a big boy so I got two big
guest uh big names big bodies huge I
don't even know if I introduce you to
you got Rampage the legend Jackson here
you got Bradley meet me at 260 Mark how
much you weigh right now probably like
uh 250 last time I damn but you look
both of you guys trim the three of us
yeah man we got our together we
kind of all three of us really trimmed
up man you did yeah I I had I got tired
of being a fat ass yeah you're like me
it shows in your face like right when I
saw him like damn R page getting getting
skinny yeah I I I I found out if you let
enough girls sit on your face it makes
your face get what does it that what
does you got to let get pink eye no no
no you get pink mouth you just focus on
that and not the food yeah no you just
focus on you let them sit on your face
and they be twerking on your face is
exercises your face damn that's what did
it that's what did you got the jaw like
that I know you you got a good jaw line
but what it was just uh you just you're
not are you getting ready for a fight or
something why why you decide to get your
together yeah like I said I got
tired of being fat ass but um I want to
do some boxing before I get too old I
trying to fight that guy on Shannon
Briggs we went to Saudi Arabia we met
the uh the king or the prince or
whatever he is and he asked me if I want
to fight um lenx Lewis I like hell yeah
lenx Lewis by money dude they want to do
a Legends um League out there I want a
Legends belt we you know just fight old
that be so dope you versus
on of course old
dude you vers Lewis and I
would love to see that dude them boys in
Saudi Arabia Abu Dhabi they got all the
money that's why they that's why they're
taking over fighting they're starting to
slide in the DMS the NBA players like
the the soccer like they're slowly just
because they have unlimited money dude
I'm trying to make the a money d That's
a level dude that be cool I want to get
in shape I've been training I started
training with this uh social media guy
his name Sean Rez was that a good idea
you think yeah cuz he knows his I
I've never met anybody that knows
nutrition like this guy oh when you mean
social media he just has a big fall in
Social a background talking about the
diet though yeah but he know he knows
everything about di you know what he did
right away he he cut my sugar and carbs
and that's what did it for me then he he
he no brainer really yeah like wait a
minute yeah that's the first thing gr
away told me quit eating pizza man stop
drink sod that's why yeah that's why I'm
so mad you had pizza here and then
that's why I only ate six slices did you
really have six man I I I I fast he went
nuts so so I fast so I really didn't eat
nothing today so I'mma tell you if I
don't if I if I don't eat you guys going
to see a different side of I'm going be
a I don't want I don't
want yeah I don't want to be that but we
have pizza we've all been dieting this
our one cheat meal bradle Bradley
shredded too when he says uh like
Fitness guy off Instagram like dud you
can talk to Bradley he knows how to get
look at his tits dude he could get you
in shape now uh my coach he's all
natural though for
sure show me a picture
look at he hey hey look at me 100% hey
hey love I'm in G aot he 100% bro
Rampage you know love bro I know bro I
would bet I'll bet money bro I I love it
bro I will bet you I will bet you money
hey you stop this right now I'm telling
you stop it and I'm sure he's great look
I don't care if he was on you if he was
pissing Deca it doesn't matter I don't
care either cuz he he don't compete for
nothing I I'm telling you I'mma tell you
I'm going tell you how I know he's all
natural okay because I had I had to take
him to Japan with me for 10 days then I
had take him to Colombia with me for
like a a
week how you travel with that
you just leave it in your carry-on
yeah easy what are you talking about I I
don't know I don't know I I don't know
they don't check anything no he would
tell me CU I I've been know him for over
10 years he's been he's been one of my
friends for over 10 years here and I'm
I'm I'm not hating this guy you guys ha
I'm not he he didn't want to told me to
get off testosterone and growth hormone
he told me he won't let if he told me if
I do any performance he he would stop
training me why would he tell me that if
he does the himself I I'll tell you
exactly what he does to get like that
what's he do he fast no sugar and cars
he's the most disciplined person I know
and I see there is that I know some see
some of these pictures he looks bigger
than he is yeah he weighs like uh 197 he
could do that he got you can tell he's
not on C he's not do that again what's
his name Sean Rez Sean I'm not hating
any facet I just have skeptical hippo at
all but there are there are some guys
that are natural he's natural the guy
the guy been training since he was like
13 years old Bradley there you guys are
at 14
uh hater no I'm just saying that V hey
no Bradley you would know because you I
mean this is your business you have the
train eye gun to the head it's tough cuz
so many people say they're natural again
I'm not here I'm sure he's a great coach
so many people say this Fighters say
this bodybuilders say this like even
like Olympians would be like a man I'm
all natural bro you're 310 with 4% body
I feel like it's just the most popular
that's his dad his dad's like 60
something years old his dad's in shape
too but yeah he's been like that his
whole life now if you told me he's 240
at whatever 4% body F like that's un 5%
he's 5% body fat
19597 lb I believe it you know why
because like people think I'mma tell
I'mma tell you he he went two years with
no cheat he wanted a he he wanted a
cheat meal he fasted for 4 days to have
a cheap meal he right mentally pretty
pretty strong that's just how he is he
he makes his money he's a fitness model
now that's how that's how he makes his
money now when I met him he was like a
stock stock guy and he was always ripped
when I met him he was like one of my
party friends all my friends we used to
go party we used to go back to his house
have girls in the jacuzzi in the pool
and kicking he was always ripped like
that right and I got really fat I got
really fat and I hit him I said Sean man
how do you stay in shape all the time be
honest you on some he said no man I
ain't on nothing and he said he said I
never take anything how old is he he's
40 he's on the Lord's diet man no
alcohol he's 42 that's impressive
looking like that yeah Tre 42 he's he's
not on everybody thinks it though
and he laughs at but and I'm I'm sure he
deals with this all the time everybody
thinks sh all the time all the time to
to to his credit too I know like Tim TBO
my boy Joe clenin shredded just
naturally high metabolism they're big
and people like on steroids my God AR
man I I worked out with this guy he
works out he works out three times a day
lift weights three times a day and and
he trains card when he when I first
started training with him he was doing
two hours on StairMaster damn and he and
he he do a stair Master at level 15 the
guy's crazy I never I never met anybody
hair great beard you can tell he said
you could tell that he's natural by his
hair that that makes no sense you know
that said he said people that do steroid
they testone lose their hair your hair
not exactly true I know some guys AR
genetically people just lose hair just
based on their
genetics I didn't start losing my hair
till I started taking testosterone
really yeah you were destined to lose
your hair then the process all my
uncle's bald but my dad got a head full
of hair
so looking like that's pretty impressive
almost unbelievable that he's not on STS
but there are I will to Cav there
there's exceptions he might be that
freak like I know freaks man there's
some freaks I and there's just I met I
have met actually more specifically I've
met girls who look so insane that makes
me believe that some guys are actually
more natural than like than they
actually like cuz I see that guy like
absolutely own stairs but I've seen
girls genetically that are just insane
that make me go like H maybe even with
like fake butts or boobs like my my
girlone heard her and her mom my
mother-in-law everywhere we go people
like oh fake ass fake ass that thing all
real baby that thing yeah yeah cuz cuz
it's so much F
popular the fake ass he told he told me
he won't never take um like those drugs
because longevity he said he wants to be
in shape for for a long he wants to live
a long time he said that he said that
is unhealthy up your organs
and yeah he might be one of those
freaks proba is he told me exactly the
supplements he own most of the
supplements he ordered from from Amazon
and I did the same he gave me a list and
I ordered the too but damn he got
your ass in shap yeah I can't take that
LX Le you think Len lewi me down he
here his is here yeah yeah with the
braids I saw him salute the um the king
he was like he's like this he did the
high hail Hitler on accident yeah yeah
but Shannon Shannon Briggs still wants
to fight me and we were supposed to try
to get it for March nth but there's no
contct second two years
bro how how I want both your opinion on
this did you see the Jake Paul fight
last night you see the highlights I saw
the highlights did you see him take a
pace see I think this is a tribute to
you should appreciate this he was
wearing the Big Chain like you wear he
didn't like it I saw I saw your post you
said nah dog take it off fam yeah yeah
what's up with that why cuz he white
what the can't wear Big Chain yeah it
can't undo it you can be the only one
wearing big chain that's only for you
you can be mad at every rapper hey but
you know what real talk some people
reminded me uh some in the comment said
I stole it from junkyard dog but that's
not that's not true but I was like okay
I see I see how it is but you know what
I'm saying he come on man it's Jake Paul
he know he know what he's doing he
that's your thing yeah that's my thing
I'm still I'm he took it from you no I
don't know but but Jake's that new wave
right like he he has the younger
audience so they they're like oh Jake's
new chain sick they don't know R the
young kids don't know Rampage yeah but
he still know he still he still
shouldn't be wearing that damn chain I
wish Trump had that chain on so
bad Trump is the man Trump is the man I
could I won't say nothing Trump was
wearing the I would't say but
because of Jake's wi are you not a jake
fan did you see the knockout though I'm
a big fan of Jake you know what I don't
get it's at this point it's just these
haters are beating the same drum like oh
it's all set up it's fake I'm like bro
that guy hasn't fought in two years he
is what whatever 10 and one or 151 it
was like you know behind that jab The
Knockout who would sign up for that
that's pretty bad man everyone's like
this is fake I'm like I don't know but
but but but to be honest just to be H
I'm a fighter but it looks all his all
his Knockouts look kind of like set up
like he's making a lot of money in there
right what what if he just telling these
guys all right I'll give you extra 2
million you just then what did he pay
Tommy Fury Tommy Fury beat him yeah he
couldn't pay Tommy fury because it's
different yeah because Tommy Fury has
more clout behind all right let me ask
then what did he pay Nate Diaz who
doesn't did he knock Nate Diaz out no
but he beat but he beat him you think
Nate would agree to fight and get beat n
Nate Diaz is a good striker in MMA but
he's not a boxer he's he's a Jiu-Jitsu
guy mostly most which is why Jake beat
him but you you really think Nate would
be like yeah I'll take a died for you
Nate Diaz but did he knock Nate Diaz out
no but if they all fixed so you proving
my point I didn't say that I didn't say
they were all fixed I'm just saying what
some of them are you think I'm just
think I'm just saying I don't know what
what what but I'm just saying what if he
comes to these guys he ain't fought in
two years I give you extra two million
you let me if you just get knocked out
or what about this I come to you you
haven't fought two years everyone wants
me to fight a real B he keep saying quit
fighting MMA guys fight a real boxer you
Haven figh in two years your your dad or
your trainer was my sparring partner I
knocked him out so I feel like you knock
you out you're who you GNA fight another
dude hasn't fought two years to make no
money or you can make fight me which I'm
probably G knock your ass out but you're
at least you're get paid and the guys I
fight Jake B huge for me Isn't the whole
thing like okay now let let like a real
promoter just pick his fight instead of
him pick the fighter no why would Jake
do
that he's making the same money whether
he knocks out this dude I F in two years
or he fights Nate Diz you get with like
Oscar de Hoya okay you're finding some
Dominican who's 37-0 yeah who who God
knows how old he is beat the break like
there's real B like I'm not saying he's
making a bad choice cuz for him for
money he's making it but everyone wants
to compare him to like Canelo the like
look up the canelo's first 10 fights
you've never heard of these fight
they're cans yeah so at least he's
fighting well-known guys and making more
money than anybody it's a smart business
it's a smart business at the end of the
day if I'm Jake that's because it's
prize fighting it's not fight the
toughest opponent fighting it's prize
fighting so for Jake I even this but
then he talks about aspirations of being
Like A Champion but who's that for Jake
like with this dude he he should have
been fighting uh you know Nick Diaz next
keep fighting the most famous oldest guy
possible make all the money CU this
fight and I love Jake this fight nobody
tuned in he talk about I didn't know the
fight happened he's talking about
fighting Tyson now sure Mike Tyson Mike
Tyson but people are tuned into that
fight Rampage see what's up oh my God
anyone F that I weigh him by like 100
pounds he don't care that boy crazy I'll
fight him for sure I F 10 million
I'm sure you could get that I fight him
for 10
million has be knuckle come to you at
all I'm surprised I don't give a
about bear knuckle at
all be knuckle got I if be knuckle came
to me I'll say a obscene number that
they it would turn him away and if they
said yes I had to do it' be like one of
those that's what I did and then they
said yes and I was like can you
say text text is so funny they gave me a
real number I was like no no wow okay no
yeah who who did they want you to find
though uh the winner of verdom and JDS
oh that would have been that would have
been huge I would have tuned in and
watch I don't watch be knuckle but you
know I this is knuckle MMA too like this
is this is yeah game bread mazol
yeah that's like old SCH I was like
other what's your beef with knuckle I I
just I just um I've always had I've
always had problems with my fist I hit
so hard when you hit hard oh yeah you
got to like you got to really protect
your fist even when I hit the bag I hit
my my Jack your wrist up oh yeah man my
fist like and you'll see in beer knuckle
too like not Mike Perry that dude built
different but a lot of these guys
they're a little more tentative because
they don't have the gloves CU they're
worried about it hurts you been street
fights like it hurt you're 260 so it
hurts when you hit a yeah it's going to
hurt so those guys it's not like MMA
where they have the glove where they can
throw jab you'll see them they're kind
of tentative they're like God is it
worth it like I I want to make it count
CU they can't just you know I don't
think I don't think I would feel that
pain while I'm fighting I just don't
think I would feel that if it breaks
though there's nothing you can do you
know what I'm say I broke I broke a hand
I broke a hand in in a fight in Japan I
kept wrist or the hand no I broke which
which hand was I think I broke this hand
uh one time I was fighting in Pride I
was fighting a Japanese guy and they um
came in my room and said oh no you got
too much tape on there which they never
do like they didn't have athletic
commission and they made me take some
tape off like a little thin little L
tape I hit them the first punch I hit
him like I heard it snap and that's you
can't even punch with like you keep
fighting yeah I kept fighting
but you can still Yeah I broke this one
B yeah I knocked the dude out thank God
but you can it doesn't hurt in the
moment but when you get back to the
locker room like God yeah after the but
think think about Mike Perry is such a
badass he made Eddie Alvarez stop he
made Luke rockold stop like this dude's
breaking faces and you SC for life after
that yeah breaking faces who they
talking about him fighting next I
thought it was it was I saw it it's GNA
be hard for them to find somebody to
fight L Perry yeah I know who's going to
sign up for
that who who should we U vote to fight
Luke Perry so since people gonna be
scared to fight him who who's out there
to fight Mike Perry mik Perry my
bad hey y'all know I'm y'all know I'm a
little um punch drunk yeah yeah Mike
Perry uh Luke Perry is great too you
didn't know I was punch drunk just no
it's just funny when you said it lot of
CT funny when you said it lot of CT in
this room I don't got no CT
though say punch trunk punch trunk it's
the different it's the different punch
punch drunk's like the kitty name like
hey don't don't don't don't call it your
wiener call it your penis right yeah
call it punch drunk don't call it CT
same what's CT stands for uh concussion
some thank you CT CT no I don't think I
got no damn CT no I don't you're too
smart but but but CT that's like is that
when like the football players be
attacking their wives and all this yeah
like Junior s blew himself in the chest
you know yeah yeah yeah I don't got none
of that I just my my my my names I
forget names and like like like one of
your co-workers she said I like five
times God damn it I no see I I used to
chalk that up too like I lose my car
keys and like here we go like so it
begins but it's just and then certain
names like my brain can only handle I
think you can only meor memorize like
300 or 600 names and after that like you
got to delete some of that so it's
kind of messed up do I sound punch drunk
though not at all you want be on here
sharp oh sounds man I was sitting I was
hanging out with Ric Bo we had him on
the podcast how was Ric bro I'mma tell
you he sound like he's punched drunk
like a mother but he is funny as hell
because he slurs his words he slurs his
words but is that why he's funny or no
no that's not why he's funny he's funny
he's very witty really he's very witty
but he is you can tell in his speech
right you can tell his speech you should
you should have you should I would love
to yeah yeah I I H you up with this guy
that'd be dope he's funny as bro
really oh my God he was a beast Bo was
so beasty dude he's one of the
funniest boxers I ever met really yeah
surpris the out of me I wasn't
looking forward to his um podcast like
here we go yeah yeah and then when we
was talking before I was like oh my God
we need to have this guy there
translating but when he got as soon he
got on the mic I understood every word
he said there's some boxers like like
Tyson Fury I mean I'm like dude you
could give TED talks like or you could
do standup comedy he was so good just in
conversation I'm like this dude is a
beast really creative funny yeah but
what's up with what's up with Tyson fear
man what's up with his body though man
that's just you know dim the rules you
know that's that's just the genetics
given he eating he's just eating pizza
and all day or what now he's all
natural
like we're not going to argue that you
know what I'm saying like don't we
always be concentrating on the fight
yeah you got Josh EMT and Bryce Mitchell
Bryce flatter Mitchell uh it's uh round
one 433 432 431 oh damn he's a big boy
but he's brilliant but I'mma tell you
what he looked better he looked better
in 2017 than he do in 2021 though and he
was fatter though yeah it's weird it
just sits different on him who won he
beat Francis huh who won that fight for
real though for real I was sitting at
front row I had Franc I have Francis I
have Francis are we biased though you
think Rampage because he's part of the
alumni here if Francis if Francis didn't
drop him then he lo I agree then he
loses but I but when Francis dropped him
I was like bro we got to so that one
drop that made it for for for me but
then then you you go back and watch the
fight I think Francis did enough to win
but and and you got to Beat the Champ to
Beat the Champ but he dropped him he
dropped him he dropped him he did enough
and then even even in the close rounds
they're going to give it to Tyson cuz
that's his you know that's and it's a
horrible for boxing if Francis wins so
even against all that it was still damn
close so I mean Francis highest thing in
MMA he's high commodity now but we
Fighters we know who win and who lose I
don't think we going to be biased cuz we
wasn't biased with we wasn't going to be
biased with Conor McGregor when he
fought uh Floyd Mayweather like Conor
McGregor he did he did he oh damn I was
super well I was paid by Showtime to
well at least you keep it real but but
Conor did good until to he did good and
that's all I was saying because back
Kellerman me him had a bet he was going
at me I was like bro I'll bet you
$100,000 Conor lands punches he's like
not a chance I was like he's not going
to land any punches you think Floyd's
that I mean he's good but it's a fight
dog oh no way Bry took this on
short notice too and it's a disaster for
oh my God hey which which one was Bryce
the one got knocked out yes that's Josh
EMT that's Josh emit yes bro wow this a
big right hand bad knockout performance
bonus
coming that was fast oh my God camera's
going to flip off dude ah come on see
UFC keeps it real the NFL would cut the
fiser commercial not UFC they zoomed in
on look at him seing damn they should
they shouldn't have they shouldn't have
zoomed in on usually they don't I love
Bryce time I don't think they did it on
purpose yeah yeah they no they didn't
know and then producer like uh get off
get off him yeah that's why they just
that's why they just looking at him now
he took a knee what they are they going
to show a replay of The Knockout oh yeah
not of the seizure though that sucks
not the season right hand boom
flush that's a problem you short notice
fight Josh EMT That Boy Hits like a mad
truck look at that I don't know why
Bryce took this fight too legit straight
Grappler very bad striking Josh EMT good
wrestling hits like a Mac Truck and this
is how you thought this would go boom
look at Ren's face look he never saw
that he never saw that punch damn he
never he never he never look his hand is
open he's such an elite Grappler but
when it comes to striking like you can't
just be a striker a Grappler anymore
that's the punch that gets you did you
don't see he never saw it that's what
the worst that's the worst the worst and
that's fullblown like all power cuz he
was here with it bad wow he's never
going to be the same after that that's
going to be tough that's a tough one
that's a tough one come back from just
because of fear or did it go backwards
it's going backwards right now though
you get knocked out and then you having
a seizure and stuff like that it's going
to it's going to be hard especially if
he watches he's up so that's great
he he's a good dude he he gets a lot of
heat cuz you know the the flatter stuff
and the conspiracy and stuff it's just
what he's into I don't you know people
want to on for but if that's what
he's into you know do thing but he was
like I challenged Joe Rogan debate on
Flat Earth I'm like you don't want those
problems I'm telling you good at
debating oh what of the best I'm telling
you you don't want those problems son
like you think you have problems now you
go on there and debate Rogan and he
knows what you're going to debate good
but this but this is the thing about the
whole Flat Earth round earth thing like
why why people care if if people believe
in the Earth the way the B the Bible
describes it why do people get so mad
about that does the bible describe his
flat yeah it does with the Dome the
firmament everything oh that's news to
me that's new you never read the Bible
no that's the problem that is a problem
go to hell so so why why people get why
do people get mad at people if they just
describe the Earth the way the oldest
history book describes it yeah so this
mean you think it's flat yep you do yeah
I do I just don't talk about it cuz so
like something like Einstein said you
know what I'm saying to to a dumb
ignant sound
dumb so I like I get it dude I love I
don't here's my thing I don't give them
like if you think they're fat do you
though I don't know why people care like
as long as you're not like some crazy
woke left person we good baby other or
you try drive a Tesla dude other than
that we good outside that I don't care
what if you're gay if you're voted for
this guy I don't like this whole Gary
stuff this whole I don't know if you
guys know what's going on with Ian Gary
like all the stuff going on like oh his
wife was a wag and she hustled him and
you know and and his uh her ex-husband's
is nutritionist and he's a cck wait wait
wait I care about that type though
I don't give a as far as he's not my boy
but as a fighter I'm like why are you
guys on who gives a what
he does in his off yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's not okay I know I know what
you're saying that that type of I just
hate I just hate this is this the type
of guy I am if I got a if I got a
homeboy and I hey let's go to the club
let's go let's go have some fun do this
let me ask my wife I hate that I
have friends like that let me ask my
girlfriend let me ask my you think he's
doing that I don't think that's what I'm
just saying that's a type of that's a
type of like if it was like one of
us like if it's your boy I get that's an
issue but if it's if they told me
Leonardo Di Caprio was a I'm like
I'm still seeing his mov yeah okay okay
yeah I see it get him like but he's a
phenomenal fighter what he does I
don't know the mother long as he's not
racist or being mean to people I don't
care yeah like said I don't I don't I
don't I don't know the
yeah you're right I just I just can't
stand for for any guy to go through some
like that because the thein
feminist movement has kind of like lit a
fire on my ass and pissed me offz my mom
was a feminist I grew up with a feminist
in my house my mom my Mom hated men my
mom treated me like because I I
looked and act like my dad so I hated
that you know what I'm saying I get it
you feel me it's not good I think I
think this stuff's happening more and
more though because like people are
realizing like to self fights and all
this stuff it's more about the drama
around it but just Ian didn't ask for
that his problem is if he was
inauthentic and was trying to copy Conor
McGregor and he's really talented if
he's not talented no one cares like he
should take some of this he's young so
hopefully he can Channel some of this
the reason they're coming after you is
cuz you're good dude you're a
superstar he's so good so he's once in a
generation tal he's so talented
but real though real like if
he can deal with this storm he's
dealing with and he got he got pneumonia
legit I know for a fact he got pneumonia
I know every wants to make fun of him I
know for when I tell you I know for a
fact you tested him I have friends who
did I have friends who did no he gave my
my coach he gave my coach no I like your
coach I don't want any I like him he's
shredded dog all natural but um what I
was saying is he if he can get by all
this storm God damn it feels next
to Jared Leto God damn it oh
they're
touching who was that guy Jared Leto who
that actor the other guy Theo one of my
best friends I know I know I see him on
Tik Tok all time he's so funny funniest
person in the world funniest person of
all time but um what I was saying if if
uh Ian Gary can get by this storm
he's dealing with and Zone that out and
just win fights he's going to be good
you know what I'm saying but he's so
young he can't let it get to him how old
is he 27 26 26 but he has to realize
like the reason they coming for you cuz
you're a superstar if you were just on
the prelims this isn't happening dog
people see the potent like this it's in
he's in the right now but he should
realize like the reason is happening
because you're so talented I got one
question though did did he take his her
her her his wife's last name or some
madeen name made that's her oh was
that his name Ian Machado Gary and she's
Brazilian I think right it's her made in
name so his name his name's Ian Gary but
now when they got married he took Ian
Machado Gary okay I thought they I
thought little soft where I come from
yeah yeah yeah but I thought it was the
ex husband's last name why did he no no
no no that was just something Kobe said
you know a lot of Brazilians do that you
know that right you know a lot of
Brazilians their last name is not Gracie
really so they get married to a Gracie
something like that and they take the
girl the dudes do yeah cuz just cuz they
want that label they want that label
Grace so that's in in the world of MMA
that's not so uncom commmon oh interes I
didn't know that but even it's like all
right why take his girl is bad too his
wife is bad why take any other man's
name though it yeah it's that where I
come in America right America we don't
do that you married already right yeah
dog she took my name she took your name
yeah when I got married my wife didn't
she didn't take my name that would
bother me it would bother you that's why
you guys aren't together anymore no
that's not why I mean well that's just
one of the red flags we can get into it
if you want I no I married a Japanese
woman oh what are we doing I thought
they were kind of like passive yeah she
was she was passive but she came to that
name change she didn't want to change
her name and I didn't and I didn't give
a what was it well her last name is
it like common Japanese no it's not Kim
no no it's not super common that's not
think
Korean uh Cheeto yeah no she she she
didn't take my last name and she gave me
a good excuse she was like I don't know
how to do the paperwork I like okay you
cool but I I I told I told her I told
her that's a bit of a cuck move on
your that you're dipping your toe in the
cuck pool no no never would dip my toe
in the cuck pool you hey you
take those words back a little bit take
those words your wife didn't take your
last name went that's understandable no
yeah I didn't give a though and you
jump in your Tesla beep beep oh it's
up no I didn't give a she
cuz I gave hey I gave her a pass because
she was she was Japanese and she didn't
want to um even get American citizen
whatever green C oh damn she was about
that life yeah she she don't like
America this is opposite nday fiance she
wanted you to go to Japan take bro Japan
is so dope I just got back my brother
was just oh you might have been there
same time he said like he said there's
no crime everyone's so respectful he
said in the shops you just go in and
then you got to leave the money a lot of
the different shops he said a lot of
shops like because there's like the
workers like in the back like they don't
steal so Jay was like I bought a jeans I
was like where is it and she's like oh
just leave the money there like it's a
trust system respectful there they got
cameras everywhere anyway so I love
Japan was it great I could live hey I
could live there if I lived in Japan
though I'd be a ho oh I could have told
you that I would have been I would been
a ho dude bro is Fergus fighting next
Ferguson fighting Patty pinet next bro
trained David do trained him I I want to
talk about the Leon and the Kobe uh
situation what did you think about what
he said about his father this is
crossing line to here's I'm not
defending Kobe I'm a big Kobe fan I I
like Leon too I'm not defending him in
any facet but once Kobe he did he did
okay okay come on what the no we do
got to stick together we are the Public
Enemy right now but no um he did an
interview after they went that was like
some dude was literally called him out
was like that was too much to the dad
why would you do that he goes do you
know why his dad what his dad did he was
a human trafficker he was a pimp he he
was a drug dealer he sell fent and all I
I would assume that's why he did this
yeah but you should have fact checked
that well that's even worse if he
made all that so Edward uh Leon's
father was shot and killed in London
nightclub when the MMA star was a young
teen he was prevy said his father was
involved in organized crime uh my dad
was a gang leader in my area and so I
was one of the few kids had a bicycle
and a skateboard I tried to look up
details I couldn't find that many I'm
sure Kobe did some research gang leader
you think the gang leader holding a
Kumbaya every night you don't
think he's trafficking hoes selling
drugs okay but think about this though
block up just think about this though
I'm not saying he should have said
anything about his dad I'm just saying
that's why Kobe said it and you're like
all right his dad was into the dark Arch
play stupid games Win stupid prizes a
little bit there and when I heard when I
heard this I didn't I I knew
nothing about uh Edward's dad me neither
I that's too much I'm with you on that
okay I knew nothing about that and I was
mad I went straight to Twitter cuz I was
mad and stuff like that you said
enough's enough because he's a criminal
you didn't care no no I'm I'm saying
that's why Kobe said that CU because
Kobe's point was like you know how many
Dad if his dad's a gangler and he killed
people you know cop out he's like what
about those families what about those
victim that could be a cop out man he's
a good talker but that's agre we don't
have facts on that but but but put
yourself in his shoes like do can we
control what our parents do like in in
the past my my my dad used to be an
alcoholic and and used to do drugs and
stuff he's a different man now uh thank
God he's still alive to change his life
right but God forbid my dad would have
passed away at that time for for me I
can't control what my dad do and I would
like to I want still my dad I don't want
to hear nobody saying that I'm going to
see your dad in hell don't get Twi don't
get twisted over the line over the line
like there's trash talk and then when
you do that it's just like that makes
you oh man that's not fun now I'm out
like when you guys talk to each
other and do that thing I like that
that's I'm on board for that but then
once you get in the personal stuff it's
like d a dead father a dead parent it's
like oh too much bro but in Kobe's mind
he's like people I'm already public
number one people hate me because he's a
big Trump guy and talks all this trash
but also he wants Leon being aggressive
he his whole thing he wants Leon being
pass getting aggressive and he's like
this is people are going to hate me they
hate me anyways if I say this he's going
to be so upset he's going to fight you
know with emotion he's going come
forward I can take I understand that cuz
if Leon smart just sits back and picks
Kobe apart it's going be a long night
for Kobe there's a reason Kobe's an
underdog so he was like I'm I'm throwing
here we go caution the win it I can
understand how about your dad and then
he knew it was going to get a reaction
out of him now I wouldn't do it even if
it was a title fight I would I would
never go that low but Kobe's goingon to
kobby and I I don't I don't agree with
it it's dark as hell I would I liked
Kobe until he said that I thought I
thought it was funny when he asked how
many people uh Ian the Ian stuff
to me is funny I thought funny yeah it's
all now how do you feel about uh Patty
with the cornrow cult appropriation or
no he cool man yeah he's cool he's one
of my favorites yeah yeah you fighting
you got long hair you fight you want to
do some like that now now if he had
now if he had uh cornrows and a d Rag
and you know some yeah yeah earrings
then guess what I accept I was like
what's up my
like he said the earrings that sh
was funny yeah with the earrings oh my
God I like Patty the B he had me on his
um
love dude this he has so much talent he
like he has so much Charisma as soon as
you meet him like oh I get it because I
I didn't I've never met him before I've
been a fan he did food truck we had to
meet him down in San Diego as soon as
you meet him you're like oh I get it
dude you're Superstar bro I like I like
most CES but he Scala right Liverpool so
you know you know they they the
of England though did you know that I
didn't know that you know I used to
train out there that's right at wler
yeah yeah bis in the yeah the scousers
they the of England they don't
they don't got no native there
that's what the scousers are really real
what I just told you was fat
everybody else look at them like the way
people look at here really yeah
it's real talk damn I so I like them but
they're the toughest right like they're
known as like they they know they they
like people when you go to when you go
to uh Liverpool like people from other
places tell you he watch your wallet
they got tough people out there man cuz
Darren TS from Liverpool got him yeah
you got some but but did he know what
what the word baded meant in America
when he when he baddy did he know what
that meant when he came to no here means
bad right he didn't out there it
means something different oh so so he he
didn't know how his name would translate
they call him the fifth Beetle that's
how famous he is in Liverpool he can't
walk down the street he was selling out
Arenas before he's in the UFC so when
the UFC came to him he was like I don't
need to why was he so popular cuz he
looked like a massive he he was in cage
Warriors out there and their biggest
organization he was the champ and he was
the Liverpool's like Star so he would
sell out Arenas before he came to the
UFC so when the UFC offered him he had
to take a pay cut he he like well I
better do it just because I got to
compete against the best he took a pay
cut now he's making more money than God
but who wins this
fight uh uh brain says Patty all day
heart says Tony you train with David
dokins you go through hell week with
David goggin you don't think he's
something special in the tank pretty
dope here's the thing though David
Goggins can't help body respond quicker
and it can't help your chin those that's
what Tony needs is is is is um David gin
going to be in his Corner yeah he's he's
there man can you imagine the guy
cussing you out while you getting your
ass kicked get your ass up
quit being a bro that guy's so
intense man he intense bro would you
train with him hell yeah I train with
him for like like 10 minutes yeah 10
minutes that's how I give him yeah me
too I'd I'd like I'll I'll train with
David 15 minutes every Wednesday
I see I see him I see I'm a fan of
because his mind is so strong look at
him look at his face this is his first
time cornering somebody in the UFC yeah
yeah but even he said he said I got him
ready physically he goes now the mental
part and when it comes to fighting and
the chin and the techniques that's not
my that's out of my pay grade like so
that's on him but as far as physically
he's he's ready to go I think I think
David gin should start training a lot
more uh MMA fighters you know what if
Tony Ferguson looks phenomenal he's
going to have H sh DMS are going to blow
up Conor's next I bet he's get blown up
look at him he gives a about these
cameras he don't give a dude he's a
Savage dude yeah I love he's pretty
motivational he's dope as I I'll
come across his Instagram post every now
and then and I'll be like you know saw
people who like trying to copy that
like running they trying to like be
motivational you can
bro but something happen something
happened to him for him something had to
happen he's really fat right right he
was like 300 350 lbs lost all that
weight and became a Navy SEAL they said
he was so rough the Navy Seals hated him
cuz he he like wanted to
quit no but something happened maybe
something he's not talking about
something happened I agree like me I
quit drinking recently cuz something
happened to me me too what happened me
too what what happened it was bad what
happened what happened driving no you
got cocked no hell no never okay not
never a God damn he was big as then
what happened you're not going to tell
us it cuz you L tell tell what happened
it ain't enough alcohol in a world for
me to get cooked okay good good but but
what happened to make you change just
stop drinking and G you just b d I was
in I was in Vegas and I got so
drunk that I got robbed at
thong Point damn you're in a th by some
by some girls I stripper yeah damn
happens the best of us dog man she got
me for almost $200,000 worth of
what the what she she was hot though huh
she was hot as yeah I get it what
as wait what did you have on you that
was my jewelry and
she said give me that and gave it
to Jake Paul yeah she probably gave that
to Jake Paul damn yeah damn fight
that make you sober up though 200k in
the in the the hole make you drink yeah
man I said that I ain't I never
want to drink after here now I never
getting I'm like I'm never getting drunk
again I haven't Dr my biggest test going
to be uh New Year's in um Japan I'm
going to watch one aretta defend his
belt in risen oh that' be dope oh dude
how about Bellator sell in the pfl yeah
sh how do you feel about it you're Bator
guy I was I mean your UFC guy mainly
I the first I one of the first ones to
go to Bellator how do you feel about it
I don't give a about Bellator yeah
sure yeah wait selling SS there's a lot
more there what selling it to who
Bellator sold to pfl so pfl oh they all
own the same yeah so pfl owns and
they're all Saudi money so pfl owns
Bellator now so you're going to have
they're still going to do Bellator then
you're going to do a like basically
Super Bowl of Bellator fighter Champions
versus pfl Champions like once a year
it's interesting they're still not
touching the so big man no UFC is
Coca-Cola everybody else is josta yeah
hey how did you know what I meant when I
said I got robbed at thong point a lot
of people don't why else would you be in
a thong dog I wasn't in a thong she was
in a thong oh my bad dog what the
you think this is I think I'm a
cook and wearing a th thought that would
so you up if you're in a
thong no way I'm going to my grave he
have a thong on though he's a freak dog
I don't know who to I don't know who to
cheer for I like both I just want a good
fight I don't want Tony get starched in
the 30 seconds and then Dave goin's like
all that work my heart is with Tony
Fergus me too my brain's with Patty and
I I love both these guys now here's the
thing I think if Tony wins he fights
Conor McGregor next uh
uh Conor ever gonna fight again
yeah yeah he'll fight Chandler this uh
well next year why is Conor fighting he
he got he's over over over 100 million
why would he
fight here's the problem though you
train with David Goggins you go through
this hell camp this only a 15-minute
fight it was five rounds then yeah Daddy
that fourth and fifth I feel like
Ferguson's always had that gas tank
though how old not that David goggin's
gassy how old is Ferguson 37
38 and how old is
Patty
12 he's young he's young super 20 like
20 what yeah he must be 20 is 39 damn
whoa he's 28 so 28 okay 39 tough off bro
I'm 40 right now you 40 40 you young as
and you got all that gray out on
your face well I used Just For Men the
other day you didn't use enough I know
well I look ridiculous I look like Tom
celic for about minutes see you married
so you don't care no more that's what
happened when you get married yeah well
no I I I did die um and it was a
disaster I looked horrible damn just
quit being cheap go to the barber shop
you rich bro go to get you a barber and
then come to your house or come here or
whatever t a week die yeah die and line
you up I got a barber that lives close
up here really not too far away he's the
best meic dude no he
black you can do it I don't know if
that's F they diet why not man you want
to go to a black barber bro yeah yeah
they are the best with Fades and
even though I had long
hair they beard too feel like it's a bad
match have you ever used Just For Men no
how old are you 34 I almost forgot you
saw that 34 you're young do just for man
it has to be a joke everybody looks like
DJ Ked when you put that on I
looked horrible I look good with Just
For Men it running out right now you so
black though that's that's what she
That's Just For Men yeah yeah yeah and
when you in a thong got robbed you got
be up I wasn't in no thong bro
hey it's all good daddy 200k happens hey
hey I'm not telling you
you we what were you wearing I had
all my clothes on she was a stripper and
gunpoint no he was too drunk I was too
drunk and I and I passed out she stole
my whole luggage that I I've heard of
this happening with dudes with Rolex and
stuff but least 200k though yeah man I
had AP and some other jewelry that hurts
my soul man he St my PR boots yeah damn
what she going to do with those damn
they're really this I had my Bellator
jacket the heavyweight tournament jacket
damn that's Irreplaceable
Irreplaceable Patty got hit though he
he's getting hit yeah he's getting hit a
bunch the the problem is is Tony as long
as get knocked out wore this out and
have the stand for I don't know if Patty
does but this is a no win for Patty cuz
you beat Tony goes yeah he's lost seven
out of the last eight who gives a
you lose to him it's you know it's G get
tough for him but I do think Tony fights
Conor if he wins his fight which is what
I want for Tony because you want a guy
to make a ton of money and be able to
ride off in the sunset yeah you don't
want to see him lose to Patty pay on Oh
that's oh first he need to keep
them hands up now he really does he he
he needs to I want I want mind him
wrestling a little more I don't know if
those knees are still working oh but
he's not trying to wrestle clearly that
boy can wrestle how is B on how is B on
the ground really good that's that's his
strongest his striking is very low level
for the at this level in lightweight
division but his grappling is high level
that's why that's probably why Fergy
don't want to take him down but Fergie's
nasty down there in the transitions the
darus is and
anacondas oh oh oh he in trouble oh he's
in
trouble that's it that's David goin's
walking in the locker room right now
oh wait wait wait wait he's still in
he's still he's still in it he's still
in it you got to block those you got to
block those he needs to go for you
got to block those no no Tony you gotta
you gotta block those Tony Tony's nice
on his back with the elbows o oh ride it
out 30 seconds 30 seconds come on DAV
Goin be so mad if you only fight for 5
minutes come
on got oh come on you got to don't let
him flatten out let him I'd rather BL
those referee you got to block those
grab him
up 20 seconds brother man he's still
good he he go to your back and survive
there you go he's good with his defense
there there you go go turn into him turn
turn
turn yeah I like Tony in the guard there
5 Seconds four seconds as long as
he get knocked down 30 seconds we good
Tony's nose bleeding like a faucet oh
man man yeah
10 round where I come from David Goin is
so mad right now I wish we could hear
what the daveid is going to say oh
what's going through I'd love to hear
what's going through his mind he's not
even in the corner he's not giving
technical things oh he's not he's right
there he's right there on the back look
at look at him uh oh what is he
saying like let me I'm a lip reader okay
you got it damn you got Trump Kid Rock
and Mario Lopez in the back let me read
his lips what he saying he's not saying
nothing
yet he said get your thumb out your ass
he is is
stupid take it take it to
him ah I'm so curious what David's
saying right now yeah he's not saying
much right now let me see he's he's
letting the coaches give him some
technique then he's just gonna maybe he
has like code words I bet he talks in
code now put it together get in this
fight he's GNA say all right Tony it's
time he said him it's that nacho
Madness like talking code you
know nacho Madness who knows all watch
watch Tony come out be a new man now
watch Tony F come out be a new man now
you know that cardio's there you got all
those ticktockers in the back he's going
to get nothing he's going to get knocked
out though he fight it's going to be bad
oh he's almost he almost failed
tripping on that monster but this how it
goes man 39 you're fighting some young
line scow at that man his Corner are
tell him keep the hand up there you go
keep it up
there that kick is tough on the
knees damn dude Tony's tough cuz his
style so athletic and he needs all the
mobility and then when the age catches
up to you that that's the first thing to
go he on orod oh yeah he's on orod as
hell does Patty get tired cuz he looks a
little he looks a little right now yeah
he he's not Tony like Tony will keep
going I like Tony from the guard he's
nicer with the elbows he has that Eddie
Bravo guard here that 10th Planet guard
he's nice with rubber guard the elbows
he's really good with remember submitted
Kevin Lee from his back with a triangle
elbowed him first so I actually like it
better down here for him than on the
feet that was about 10 years ago D no
not 10 but probably probably five yeah
man so is it is it like an age really
where you're just like all right this is
it big time and there's some freaks like
Randy Couture Brock Lesnar but in
general or Rampage but in general I
aged overnight just one day hit you I
think I think so just one day just hit
what did you notice most different how
old are you Rampage I'm
45 like is it like just your endurance
that the first thing I noticed about my
age is that my nuts got shriveled up
like that could have been the trt cuz
mine got super small on it I I haven't
done trt in a long time though oh
oh yeah that your boy has you vegan and
no test I ain't no vegan steroids
at all you've done steroids before no
that guy doesn't do steroids I was
talking about your guy your we're not
talking about me
who we're not talking
this on Bradley wait a minute
dude hold the
on oh it's so funny man yeah there's
just certain age where you get like I
but what goes first what went first for
you like my
hamstrings your hamstrings just popped I
was sprinting against my buddy and both
just popped I was like oh I'm 40 I think
your speed goes first but it's it's not
on that I think it's like your uh your
coordination or something you see how he
moving and stuff like that yeah your
little you just get stiff like your
joints aren't as mobile and then um but
heavy weights can fight longer cuz
they're not they don't rely on their
movement as much as like a 155 like Tony
so heavyweights they you can they last a
lot they're older so they reach their
Prime later the lightweights and like
even below that the feather weights and
you know that that it man the
athleticism bro dude okay
yeah it's like wide receiver in the NFL
you better you got to be
pretty on your peeves and
cues I a gray hair in my pebe I was like
d I'm getting I'm a dad I got three kids
gray hair in your I did wow I did that
got to be embarrassing for yourself oh
yeah it was tough it was I haven't had
that yet I a't had no Grays in my pubes
I got one gray in my nostril though I
hate that one that bumps me out I've had
that you know when you getting really
old when the hair comes out the ears bro
how do you not know my manager like
sorry dude he has it hanging out here
I'm like bro just manscape that
manape the bar don't tell him
godamn his girl don't tell him and I
hate when your nose hairs connect to
your mustache I hate that that
happens to him too I'm like bro how do
you not know this is a look I hate
when I see when I'm talking to men and
they got long nose hairs oh nothing
worse I'm like how you got a wife the
the gray The Gray nose hair is
disgusting yeah I I put that just for
man I'm I'm my nuts I'm me nuts did you
really yeah dog wow yeah DED how many
gray hairs did you have down there it's
just that one man why you care about hey
don't no y talking yeah give that last
name she didn't want to take it no y'all
talking about me wearing thongs and
when I said I got WR you saidong I got I
got I got robed I was in a thong no I
said I got no I said I got robbed at TH
I got robbed and I was in a thong I
didn't say that I said I got robbed at
thong Point th so I'm thinking she she
has a gun and you got a thong
on I thought I thought some Oscar De La
Hoya or dog C The Thong
Song cuz it gets freaky man you never
know like you're so rock hard and she's
like just put this song on like whatever
it takes dog right like I just put these
panty hes on these boxing you think
that's what happened with him yeah and
he was like you was so bad he's like I
don't give what what what do you want to
do high heels yeah you got a 13 you
don't think he was into that but why is
he posing for those P I've seen those
pitches I seen him too why what how many
times have you seen him a handful
handful I saw it once and I'm I see I
saw once was getting I came back to him
in a week you know I'll check in
monthly it'll get brought up on a
podcast once a month if De La Hoya had
only fans will you subscribe I check
that out the Golden Boy on only
fans doing some little something strange
for some change was you do only fans no
hell no my dick too small I don't want
everybody seeing that no you ain't
fooling nobody sh I Ain I ain't letting
everybody see all that hey I just did an
interview today cuz John singon um you
know he passed away and they doing like
a they're G to do a documentary story
about him and he reminded me Legend yeah
uh he the one who got me the 18 movie
originally a lot of people didn't know
that he I yeah he was going to be the
director but he he CED out because he
didn't like the direction that was going
to go and um so but he he wrote a movie
for me and he was going to make the
movie damn wait who johnon he did like
boys in the
hood Superman I thought you said John
Cena he loved him he loved me he the
reason why I got that role cuz I knew
what they was looking for right nobody
else knew everybody thought they was
looking for Mr T damn but John singon
told me exactly how to go do the
audition everything right so he was
going to have this character named brick
I'm not going to tell you the whole
story cuz they might make it I don't
know but the one I turned the movie down
I said John I can't do I can't do that
movie cuz he wanted me to be doing some
sex smashing like this fat white girl
then oh you have a problem with that
yeah yeah and then come was in Japanese
that's why turn down so stereotypical
that's so but he wanted me to open the
door butt naked everybody see my John I
can't bro a John Cleon movie I gotta be
naked you do a John singon movie and you
got to be naked I don't give a you
know what kind of gu I'd be on for that
my mom going to see that movie Love I
would have done it John C that is an
honor I told him I'd do if he if he
found a double dude you're telling
me you wouldn't be Batman you wouldn't
be B Batman if they're like but there's
a scene where where you're hooking up
with some fat white girls it wasn't that
it wasn't that part that I turned down
was cuz he wanted me to open the door
but ass naked that one scene I said I
can't do that scene you could do it Dirk
digler style Mark Wahlberg where they
had a body double that long that's why I
told him he was like he said no he said
he gonna be the whole thing he said he
don't want to do no body for John singon
I would have been like say less son I
would have done it you would have done
it now would you do Brokeback Mountain
whoa what the was that oh
you don't want an Oscar I don't give a
about an Oscar oh I'm gay cuz I
want an Oscar yeah you and I want I'll
act like a gay cowboy yeah you want
Oscar you want Oscar de la
Hoy you want to be the Golden Boy you
tell me you wouldn't do a broke R
Mountain to if you can guarantee an
Oscar no how much how much how much 30 m
no you crazy you kiss man you got to
kiss a man you broke back bound dog it's
the least of your
words that's the easy part yeah that's
the easy you be shoot those scenes fer
is in his fight Fergus in his fight now
yeah you get guillotine here
maybe
damn David gogin might be out of the UFC
after this he might man that yall
some huh he got soft man yeah
yeah but he knows how old here comes
that triangle he's trying to step that
triangle but Patty's well versed on the
ground it's just even on the ground
Tony's awkward so he might be able to
catch with some he should keep keep up
with those elbows though he should
that's his thing El right I'd rather
have Tony down here than on his feet on
the feet he's just too stiff there's
David look at him what is he saying read
his lips read his
lips how much does know about MMA though
not a lot but he knows I get trash and
J move go
move get your ass up and
move he does cuss a
lot having done this how much does
something outside even help not a lot
yeah yeah so whether it was Bruce Lee or
David Goggins there not especially when
you're ass who dudes on top get up no
dude yeah come on get going yeah
yeah I'm trying dude yeah I figured that
was the thing the worst one when I was
fighting Gonzaga was third round I was
exhausted I was beating the exhausted
from beating the brakes off I was so
tired my coach yelled out 3 minutes and
45 seconds left I took I'm like God be
my day up so tired let me know when
there's a minute left exactly what are
you doing exactly I hate that hated it
hated it oh never tell me a minute and
30 seconds that's all I want to know
3:45 Brandon keep keep it going I'm like
wow it it you mentally so far away
from wow close what are you doing yeah
it really with you you never had
MMA fight yet no no one want wants that
smoke she he's been asking she he been
asking for it though huh no he in my
weight
[Laughter]
class come on Fergie but you've kind of
backed off of it right Bradley yeah you
still you were messing with it like I
mean I've been you get in shape too
you're you're lean right now been tring
MMA I've been training who you training
with I'm I'm well David gogins David
gogin yeah David Goin yeah I've been W I
mean I was talking about W and Logan but
because I feel like they're all going to
go towards that way yeah the next that's
what it seems like the next Edition for
them would be MMA I'd assume pfl or
something so I've been doing some some
stuff here but you're so much bigger
than them still yeah but he's a you know
obviously he's had more fights so he's
got that Advantage who who you talking
about Logan Logan Paul uh MMA yeah he's
a good wrestler yeah and he he's a good
Striker you don't want to fight him yeah
I do Bradley Bradley 260 though I do you
picked Brad Bradley over Logan no I
ain't never he he ain't never had a
fight true but I don't know what martial
art you know what martial art you know
ass kicking I mean I've trained mu Thai
how long two years oh okay no no two I
know two years bro two years in mu Thai
can be good enough to keep him from you
know what I'm saying getting knocked
down in the first 30 seconds I trained
Jiu-Jitsu how how long you trained
Jiu-Jitsu since two years three years
that's that's good if he got the right
trainers that could be some and he's a
big athletic like Bradley can dunk how's
this cardio lot a lot a lot better now
yeah that's why he's that's why he's
leaning up yeah but I I you're almost
too big and strong I feel like it's such
a liability the last round yeah last
round that's the last round it's been
you know but like he said he thinks he'd
win so then he should fight me why not
You' you'd fight Rampage no no no no
Logan Logan win so it's like it's easy
for Logan yeah true so that's a big
fight too I get I get a fight to
Fergie you give that to Ferguson yeah
Ferg he he lasted to the end give it to
the old man yeah I don't feel like
that's what they're going to do I don't
depending on what these judges do
there's going to be a lot of people
super upset because if they use
DraftKings to bet on UFC 296 DraftKings
sports book is going to help you come
out on top in this epic bout between
kobby comton Leon Edwards shovot and
Wonderboy is next then you got the
co-main event uh Brandon Roy Val's doing
work and then you also got the main
event there's still time to bet at
DraftKings all you got to do all you got
to do is download the draftking
Sportsbook app right now use code shop
show new customers get $150 instantly in
bonus bets for betting just five dollar
ruse only draftking sports book the
official Sports spreading partner of the
UFC with the coach shop show the crown
is yours hit it chener Casey I can't I
can't I okay right read the warning here
we go all right uh the crown is yours
gam call 1800 Gambler or visit
www.8 wait wait 1 1800 gambler. net in
New York call
877 hope and n y orex hope and Y 467
hold on 467 369 in Connecticut help is
available for problem galling call
8977 7 or visit ccpg dorg please play
responsibly on behalf of booill Casino
Resort in Kansas 21 plus age varies Oh
by jurisdiction void notaria bonus bets
expire 168 hours after issuance see
dk.com
for eligibility and deposit restrictions
terms and responsible uh gaming
resources damn that was tough it was
tough dude is that is that referee is
that Dr
Dre what happened where right the ref
that's Dr Dre they gotc got Dr Dre ref
no that's Dr Pepper that that dude is
too thick yeah they gave it to him for
sure yeah yeah yeah what does what does
Ferguson do from here retires the UFC
probably going to come after this yeah
but you can't lose eight fights and
still keep be around I've never heard
anybody losing seven six seven in
usually four is the m five they C you
what are we doing they can cut you in
the road legally in contract they can
cut you at the two Tony like he's done
so much work there for Pat the problem
with this wasn't like a crazy
performance by Patty so again it's a no-
win situation for him all right you
speed a guy who's lost one two three
four five six fights in a row okay so so
you went to decision with him so it's
it's a no win for him so what's what's
what's next to Ferg b knle game bread
probably yeah I I could see beer knuckle
offer him a fight damn I know it's not
good it's not
good Legend too there's one time what
he's the best 155 on the planet him or
khabib they're supposed to fight then he
fell over a CT at Fox blew his knee out
who ber fergon he was doing a press
thing and they were supposed to fight
like two weeks before blew his knee out
never returned the same man that's
probably what you know when you get
older and you get knee injury he tore
everything they said just he someone he
was walking out he has his glasses on
someone said Tony said what's up man
then turn boom tripped over a court boom
blew every I that dude that call my name
I I would go back and I'll be pett like
that yeah Su it all yeah I'll go back
and be Petty like
that this next fight's good Wonderboy
versus shot great fight Wonder booy's 40
or 41 too yeah yeah damn for is not old
bro no for a fighter for a fighter for a
fight especially especially at
welterweight especially at welterweight
what's interesting is Wonderboy Thompson
he came out and said he was supposed to
fight the dude missed weight and he was
like I fight you out a heavy weight and
one Bo's like nah man like you got to
make weight and the UFC was like dude
take the fight he's like nah they went
okay okay oh okay okay okay well we'll
get you a fight you want to complain
that we didn't pay you okay here's sha
Cott like they're discipline him here oh
for real oh horrible match up for him
shot's 170 17 finishes like he's the
next guy at welterweight so who was he
supposed to fight that didn't make
weight he was supposed who was he G gig
Chi gig oh Giga was Giga is tough righto
for who for Wonderboy not Giga no no no
I think Josh sorry oh was he was
supposed to fight um homeboy
Pier Michelle Pier
right let's
see but they're disciplined because then
he came out he's like they said they
were going to pay me they didn't pay me
and they're like okay dog keep talking
oh yeah for the wait Miss yeah Michelle
Pierre UFC was like all right here's
shot the Savage nobody wants to fight
probably G be champing oh I love Zack
Brown that Hat's great oh my boy makes
that hat that's one a Zack Brown ban
yeah yeah I met them a long time ago guy
right there that's my boy too oh boss
Ren damn Legends three Legends
damn yeah who wins him or DDP he's a
Savage he a pro wrestler no he's
supposed to fight that guy next for the
middleweight championship of the world
look at him Mr oh damn he's shooting him
who wins that's a tough one to call I
couldn't call it it's what I always I
always make picks that one I can't I
don't know damn that's a PR fight though
that fight in the UFC I mean in Toronto
Vegas that one's in Toronto right here
this is it right
here Sean Strickland surprised me with
uh Izzy dude so it's like did Izzy have
an off night or Sean stricken that
goddamn
good I don't think I don't think I don't
think is is rated him I don't think he
like train that's why I heard he didn't
take him serious that's why he's taking
a long layoff he's burnt out he's been
the Champ for a hot second fight big
title fights it happens yeah so he's
taking a break but if they rematch you
what you thinking the rematch I'd
probably favor isz he but Strickland's
people don't give him enough
credit man he's tough man you can tell
by his defense is filthy people like you
look at his the stats on his he the best
defense in the UFC he doesn't get hit
man for real doesn't get hit his defense
is sick but this duus uh drus depi he's
so awkward and he's big he he's just
he's hard to train for dude I met ezzy
and U Saudi Arabia he's he's big he's
tall as hell 6'4 taller he's he might be
64 four and a half cuz he's him him and
I are about the same height he's a freak
yeah man great guy right such a good
dude yeah yeah one of the best I I had
no idea he was that big me neither when
he got out and it was that time he was
calling out Jon Jones I was like godamn
he's like I'm telling you dog I'm not
that small but just size-wise like the
weights and issue
yeah man that Strickland's been so
entertaining on the internet lately wild
boy yeah whenever you see him do a
selfie in that car you're like oh here
comes some fire whenever it's a selfie
it's daytime he white shirt on you're
about to get some fire he the one who
started that whole thing about Ian U
Machado I I it might have started like
read it as like a started before started
before and then he heard it but he's the
one that took it to another where I
heard it from me too that's where I
heard it from he took it another
level and who knows what's true what's
not you don't know like Ian Garry's
hated so who knows what what's real why
people hate him before they knew all
that why did they hate him because he
was a little inauthentic he was kind of
copying com McGregor he did the the the
Jared uh Jeff Neil thing where he put
his mug shot on a t-shirt like you know
he just did some foul oh yeah he's
just looking for something and then he's
he's from Ireland and then tonight he
was going to wear Brazilian colors
that's some bro you know
you're from Dublin dog you got you got
to you got to fly the flags and then you
going do Brazil you're not from Brazil
bro my wife is all right you can't wear
your wife's colors he got and he got a
kid with her yeah she's pretty though I
get it would you smash you unmarried
yeah you guys are Fu I get H up at thong
point for her will you let Ian
watch I knew you were going with this
you stupid it's tough man it's his
wife cuz then you're not a wait
what no no you're not it's him he's
watching I know that's his thing so
you'd be a part of that the escapades if
I was single yeah if you were single you
would let you would let you let him
watch why what's he doing in the corner
who knows say something man if there's
like a sheet so I can't see him you know
like it's like behind looking like this
oh if he was like hiding in the closet
I'm like yeah whatever dude hide under
the bed whatever that yeah
whatever just don't come out
whatever you
hear damn Jameson I don't pay you guys
that bad you really drinking oh word so
um is it is it really is it really true
that her ex-husband live with them all
that's true see I heard that's fake
rumors heard the one thing they the one
thing that the only thing I know that
sticks where people you were like oh
that's not good is his wife did do like
a audible or like book on being a wag
wife what's a wag W wife and girlfriend
of athletes like like her whole goal was
to marry an athlete here's my thing with
that so she's and she used to work for
like Premier League football like real
like they make real money if your whole
goal is to be a wag why would you and
when she she got with him he was like a
cage Warrior Champion they don't make
money they make awful money so why
would she Bank on this kid who's up and
coming and even now he doesn't make he's
not balling like he's not flying private
like owning houses so if if so the wax
thing doesn't work for me now she
married a Premier League football player
like if she was like Beckham's wife I'm
not saying she's a wag but if you
married Like Beckham all right allenda
you married a broke young Prospect but
hear me out though over there they have
a system it's not like what we got here
she probably already got she probably
got flagged the guys told like be
careful about this true that does
happen that happened yeah come out here
she agendas I see what you're saying but
then she goes to cage Warriors and and
she's like this kid and she has an eye
for talent she's like this kid is the
next big thing you're going to ride it
out for 10 years in MMA what a terrible
idea yeah but she can get have a
goodlooking handsome and shaped kid and
get some dickle on the way she probably
happy but that's different than a wag a
wag just wants like the
attention she she came up with when he's
a prospect they had a a kid together she
might be cool too she might be dope yeah
so probably and she that was also what
10 years ago like she might be different
she like yeah I came that was a
knucklehead I'm 40 now she's 40 he's
26 yeah beautiful baby I'd
everybody if I see him like I don't get
I don't care look at my girl
man she wrote that book 10 years ago
yeah but I heard it's like a parody but
chin thinks it's real no cuz but Brendan
actually had me like go deep dive into
it so I actually read not read listened
to the book and it was it says 11 pages
of an audio book it was over 30 minutes
long and I listened to the entire thing
and it sucked what was your takeaway J
it reminded me of do you remember the
the game the book The called called the
game by stra it's like it's like a
pickup artist version of a girls thing
you know so chin read the game book when
he was when he wanteded to get girls and
he used to do magic and bars to get
girls what I'm saying like but it's like
it's about social skills what the game
sounds like a pickup artist thing but
when you actually read it it's like
about social skills with with girls and
guys right so with magic yeah and Magic
is involved yeah how many girls you
smash from reading that book though dude
I had more girls when I read the book
and I was so much fatter and so much you
know not whatever back then your chins a
dime now no now you're G come do a
magic yeah you do magic in the nightclub
bro I would literally do magic I do like
he dud Jeffrey D Vibes with like just
the cigarettes cigarettes cigarettes and
whatever
what the he like what's this what's
up grum chin wow anyways the the book is
more like a tutorial on how to like land
someone that's you know famous her her
book is yeah yeah so what wait and it's
like over 30 minutes long which if
that's a short book bro but I mean
listen that's like picking up a dude for
dummies you know how much it sucks to
listen to it for 30 over 30 minutes well
what was the what was like the best
point that she made then she said like
uh boob surgery ass surgery uh she said
like putting on like uh toning you know
like a sunt like a fake
T once a week not not like multiple
times because then you get two like
bronze yeah two orange all Stu there's a
ton of information sounds like she was
dropping fat yeah she talking about
girls in Miami so it wasn't like a
parody it wasn't a parody it was just
like you like you like the fake ass and
I'm the fake I hate that I hate it bro
hate it I hate sh dude that
we got to stop
that with the fake ass huh fake ass fake
lips I technology coming a long way bro
trash bro nothing like real I'd much
much prefer real let's get rid of that
man girls are getting fillers in
their cheeks and now all know some
of them are shaving down their chins I
hate this crazy someone taking
out ribs and mean I mean if a girl
if a girl is really cool she got a
really good personality you know what
I'm saying I let her slide is that Jack
Black yo dude he has Jack Black in his
goddamn Corner oh my God Jack Black I'm
a big fan of that guy I love Jack who
doesn't like Jack Black oh he got the
other guy that he's in the band with too
the other guy from Tenacious D D that's
why I call my that's why I call my penis
damn now he might win bro why yeah damn
they look yeah damn his boy from
Tenacious D looks like Santa Claus
that's why I tell girl B you want some
this Tenacious D different little
different than Tony Ferguson but you
know it's cool dude who would you rather
have Tenacious D or David gokin you want
some that Tenacious D he L that one up
that tenacious black d though who what
would you rather
have oh God Jack Black with the
tenacious G would you rather have Mr
black or Tenacious D hey they got big
worm working at too big perm big perm
big perm Big Worm oh my God UFC's really
do really doing all the stars came out
tonight and you got Trump ringside bro
the UFC on on the next level boxing
don't got no like this no no we we
overtook boxing a hot secondo a long
time
ago damnn Wonder Boy how did he get
connected with Tenacious D bro come to
Boy by yeah walkout song oh oh they're
like we're fans and he was like who
doesn't like Jack Black wow he's so good
you my kids love he follows me on
Instagram damn that's a big deal that is
a big deal he come in on one of my
movie re wow he said this is
really good yeah he I guess he was yeah
he did iess put me in Kung Fu
Panda 6 what I know I no I want I
want to be in the um the other one he
got the U one with rock what's the
what's the name you know my memor is bad
um jamuni oh bro I want to be in jamong
I like that type play Kevin Hart's part
why got why I gota be Kevin Hart you
know what you ha we going have one yeah
you
know I'm not taking No Rules from Kevin
har can't be that woke you know what I'm
saying like it's jamanji bro it's in
it's like in Africa or some like
there got to be a bunch of blacki is in
a video game right no it's a board game
it's a board game yeah yeah but now was
video movie was video the last one was
board game was with Robin Willam did you
see the first jji with Robin Williams
that's my jamanji yeah that's my jamanji
the best like my Batman's Michael Keaton
that's your Batman yeah yeah he was good
bman yeah who who was your Joker
who's your Joker chrisan Bale though
Christian Bale's good but that Mike I
mean Jack Nicholson yeah yeah to he's
good yeah and then my Riddler is Jim
Carrey yeah yeah yeah Mr Freeze is
Arnold yeah yeah yeah I agree with chill
out you just had those horrible
it's time to freeze
so so oh shav's cot shave cot how come
he look Asian because he's Mongolian so
where he's from it's from Kazakhstan but
kazak Asian Russian Asian some of them
your cousins that moved over a lot of
it's Mongolians cuz uh genas khanan
raped so many people I know that that's
no that's true that's true that's
history bro I'm a descend of genas Khan
what yeah if you got one and something
if you got uh blood type B you
descendant of gang is K I don't know
what blood type if you got if you got if
your blood type is B you are yeah well
the history book says that oh so you
can't believe everything blood type B
I'm blood type B say if you're blood
type B are you uh is genas Khan your
Daddy yeah it's like one and something
it's like one in 10 or something he
raped so many people it's like yeah it's
like one and two I don't listen I think
they call it rape but think about this
so think about this back in the day if a
if another uh if a Stormer man like a
trooper man soldiers a storm of men men
storm a storm of men a Men Storm your
your village and they killed all the men
and you K and are they really going to
rape the women or the women after a
while the women just going to be like
well but I don't think it's after a
while I think it's like it's go time
like they're not chilling out for weeks
on vacation like they take it's on to
the next V they take they take them all
with them and sex slaves he leaves some
men's he leav he leaves the men's there
and stuff I don't like men's anymore
yeah I don't know man what's it say
there's there's not a lot of
hold on see look I look just like
gangas you look a little like him dude
man dude yeah we could be twins no you
were such a
Savage what's it say about his blood
group I Tred to find some blood type
that D did so much damage I think I
think Rampage is making it up the blood
type yeah so I couldn't find it could be
bro I'm I'm sure you guys think I'm
making up but I studied my blood type I
know a lot about my what else you know
about it um I'm I do really well at high
altitudes so CIO is not an issue like
you know some people like boss Ruden he
told me he can't train the High Altitude
really it's too hard can't fight in
Denver yeah he can't he can't do it but
me I go I I adapt well to high altitude
yeah me too and and like eat right for
your blood tght I learned this but
I don't believe in it cuz see I can't
have
chicken really yeah see I supposed to
eat lamb I Des L that's shocking I'm not
supposed to eat chicken but I supposed
to eat lamb you can't eat chicken from
my blood type that's what eat right for
your blood a blood type say that is
shocking that's like me being
like I can't have peanut butter and
jelly
yeah yeah right right I I was like I I
dismissed all that that's soon I
can't have cashews you can't have
chicken wings that's what eat right from
my blood type says ain't that a
but I don't like lamb lamb is gross
Lamb's delicious lamb chops you know a
lot of times you you think you eating
lamb but you but you but you eating goat
I like how he like he like picks the
gangest content but because of the
chicken thing is like I don't know about
so G he's like G is Con but chicken
chicken that's why I've never heard of
someone being allergic to chicken I'm
with Wonder Boy because I play video
games with him yeah well dude Wonder Boy
my guy I can't remember what game it was
UFC 3 or some no hell no it's
probably Cod or or Rainbow Six Siege or
some rain oh oh you you play like
uh online with him yeah yeah yeah I
thought met you played like in the
UFC we stream we stream we were playing
video
games it it was probably pubg or
something like that I've been one of the
UFC video games I'm still waiting for
for my goddamn royalties they keep
sending my royalties to one of my old
hous Le you get
yours well you're probably a big
character I was a bonus character you
was a bonus character yeah I was like if
you buy the pack early get Brendan's job
they still should give you royalties
You' be
nice it's only $5,000 every game that
would be nice yeah that buy me some nice
car I don't think I'm in I don't think
I'm in a new game you're probably not
but I'm going talk to my manager I'm
going talk to T hey man you don't think
you aged out of the video
game do they have yeah do they pride in
there cuz they used to have the pride
cuz they have Fedor in the game you
can't have Rampage why they not have you
in there that doesn't make any bro how
about in the last last UFC you want to
talk about copyright they should have
paid you two dudes slam triangle chokes
Knockouts I saw one where's the
royalties dog yeah that's your they
should at least call it all the Rampage
they should call it the Rampage but but
uh what's his what's his name he is the
greatest knockout of all time have you
ever seen it yeah he slams the dude when
he triangle chokes him but DC said I've
never seen that before this yeah but
Rogan corrected him right I didn't I
didn't watch I would assume how dare
that's offensive that's but I think he
said I think somebody said oh he said he
never seen him before from the side cuz
he knock him out the side n that that
that's come on bro yeah you know that's
super famous that's the Rampage dude do
you know how many movies put did oh I
know copy it bro where's the I see any
movie they do that yeah they
should at least put in the criticis like
taken they have that I'm like
you tell me this random human
traffickers going to Triangle somebody
from oh I know they copied your I
saw ason Kushner do it in one of his
movies he's a purple belt under Machado
is he yeah oh you rode with him before
no I like him though wait that boy's
almost a billionaire off his Investments
ker yeah he's smart huh he's smart he
inv like Facebook Uber Acorn yeah he's
balling then his girl gets all the
Family Guy money and that 7s show
they're so filthy rich I met her I met
her Lunas yeah I Met she's Ukrainian
she's cool as bro I met right after
right after the Chuck fight when I was
champion I was doing a music video for
this one guy he had her in it too she
was sitting there teaching us how to
play Texas Hold him she didn't know who
I was and I never said anything it was a
bunch of like extras and stuff there and
she just treated everybody like and she
was single this was years ago she
probably was she probably she was
probably they was dating since the 70
show were they
yeah damn that could that could have
been you man no no she's not my you
would have took her last name no bro
hell no she's not my bro she's bro she
looks good but she's not my type she's
like straight up and down no curves she
th yeah she's no curves That 70's money
though that that I mean I smash I smash
but I keep it pushing yeah I feel you
DG you would take your last name though
for that 70s money no you got me
up hell no yeah me too man I'm just
kidding hell no yeah I would never but
is there is there is there a Hot Chicken
on the planet that you would take her
last night a good question that's a good
question oh I'd be Brandon the stallin
no no stop it God stop it stop what the
I be I'll be Brandon be for a night
you feel me I be Rampage Lopez oh I like
that what's
up I hope
so oh
God I hope so you know what I'm talking
about she's so bad yeah Kodak the Kodak
she's so bad yeah she bad she's still
bad 50 you don't have to get through Ben
affet good luck n Ben AFF ass no
you won't you ever seen the
town would you up you seen the town
how about these apples ble up all
they got to do is chicken also bat man
how about you what what girl you take I
don't think there's any man I don't I
couldn't do it man my name is so common
I don't give a yeah I Rampage Lopez
rage they're just going to call you
Rampage no matter what I mean when you
fly you know you show your passport and
like no Rampage samic what's her
name what's the name the Mexican
girlfriend hyek Rampage salmon hyek yeah
whatever I get it Rampage Hayek yeah
hell yeah she's hot she's still hot
she's old she's still hot yeah she bad
she's like 50 yeah yeah Dam I need to I
need to get off these older 50s ladies
what what's there's some cougars too man
some hike who else who's hot and younger
though I like old ages as long as
they're over 21 all Asians or all ases
oh gotcha I thought long as they over 21
all Races too like what kind what your
what I know like you equal opportunist I
get it but if you have to pick an Asian
is it like Japanese Korean CH it's
Chinese your thing hey I'm going to tell
you this Taiwan if I have to pick if I
have to pick a
Asian a Vietnamese from from Vietnam not
American one oh you trying to go Vietnam
Viet I pick AET some guilt if I had if I
no if I had to pick one is it a guilt
thing no I got I don't have guilt I
don't have guilt I don't do that I
should be guilty about I'm just saying
America Vietnam War right giv back no
the American ones I love them I love I
love the Vietnamese girl but the
American ones americ met one you never
met a Vietnamese girl I don't think I've
ever met somebody from Vietnam besides
um Manny Pacquiao on accident he's from
he's from Philippines Philippines is he
what the wow wow that's how you
know I never met one that's how you know
I never met
one name name a famous person from
Vietnam and and name name one and uh uh
uh kungi kungle you tell me kungle is
not Chinese he's Chinese vienamese
Kong is
venes name another famous person from
Vietnam Chen can you name one yeah who
Dustin M from 21 Jump Street way back in
the day though God we're digging deep
come on you talking about you talking
about famous now bro D dude we're
digging deep yeah oh turned out to
be a good fight but kungi is probably
the most famous kungi is the most famous
Vietnamese he claims did he fight with
that flag I thought he fought with the
Chinese flag Chinese it looks I think it
looks s I don't want to say that
see what he claims you want to look you
want to look it up for us CH yeah yeah
look up most famous uh people from
Vietnam he's from hoim City Vietnam
thank you he's
Vietnamese it says claim claim
China that's cool bro I want to grab
some pizza oh that pizza's fresh right
is there more left I don't know Rampage
entire hey hey hey hey I my coach might
be watching this coach I didn't touch
not one slice of that
pizza CH did you look up famous people
from Vietnam no I'll do it right now
this a good fight though I thought Manny
Paco's from Vietnam for a second that's
up man it is up I regret
that yeah cuz he he put the Philippines
so Dustin 's number
one who and I don't think anyone okay
kungle I don't think anyone knows the oh
kiwan don't act like we know him yeah
that's the guy from uh uh Indiana Jones
the kid oh then he did a new movie uh
not Dam we are reaching right now yeah
it's super reaching oh the guy from
Indiana Jones in the 7 he was a kid when
he was a kid yeah oh yeah that's that's
the new movie oh yeah that movie sucked
hey what's that venese what's that
vietamese actress name the girl she was
dating that black guy I think he was a
rapper like young jock or somebody
you're talking about Genie ma got a big
crush on her she's dud I actually met I
Genie where'd you meet her at Chen you
did Magic for her dude we actually hit
it off pretty well dude we actually hit
it off pretty well I be Rampage M bro or
would you be uh Jenkins Rampage Jenkins
no that is that his last name they
broke up right yeah they did break up
damn dude she's single so she's chinese
vietnamese bro shein bro she's hot as
we need a full blooded person from
Vietnam here but no she's Vietnamese but
they have like Chinese blood I need 100%
bro don't count I mean tough on the
street good luck on this man yeah
there's not a lot no the two that we
know or the three are kungle Dustin L
and
Kean damn man but Vietnam good food too
huh I heard it's great to Vacation yeah
it's good I'm going I'm going um on
January 2nd I'm going to the fight in
Japan Dam you always be travel then
after New Year's the next day I'm going
to go to Vietnam and visit my friends
and you got a bunch of friends there I
got a bunch of friends there really yeah
I've been there once I bet that's F once
yeah I make I make friends where I go
that's true yeah damn he put his hand
behind his back like that like he's a
top he in trouble in trouble he's in a
lot of trouble's if he's on the ground
it's oh yeah he's in you think Jack
Black stand right now oh that's
out he's not even trying to get out
though he's just trying to get him you
like that case he got that wait wait
he's out oh why did he not try to do
anything with his own hands one of the
best Jack Black movies Saving Silverman
I don't think I've seen that oh it's
good school of rock is up there that was
a that rock was fantastic good
movie like zero ground game yeah he's a
kickboxer so who's a kickboxer Wonderboy
he's not a kickboxer he's a karate Kate
karate kickbox we had 57 kickboxer is he
570 57 and0 57 and0 I thought he was
just a karate guy no wow so
for for uh shot you know he's he can
grapple his ass off
speaking of karate did you see Anthony
Pettis fight yesterday no I didn't see
it did he win yeah he won they win
overtime benon was it fun yeah yeah they
they picked it up the last couple rounds
too it's tough to get into karate bro
it's the karate combat thing yeah it's
tough to get into
it yeah but you know Anthony Pettis man
he's he's doing it all he just beat Roy
Jones love Anthony you know what
crushing is mozal mozal was his bear
knuckle MMA that that that he's crushing
dude that game bre MMA is lit the UFC
set set him up with that stuff huh cuz
they on Fight Pass huh no they're not on
Fight Pass they they for they're so
smart they it for free on YouTube so
they just want to get the name out there
so instead of you know how bare knuckle
they charge you for pay-per-view and
some like they barely get he buys uh
gamebr and Dean the the CEO of it was
like no we want everybody to have access
to it and then once we get big enough we
do pay-per-view he's choking him out
right now but uh so they do it for free
you got 15 seconds he's tapping he's
he's out's didn't go to sleep he got 10
seconds he heard that he maybe he can
hold on for 7 Seconds No 5 Seconds Jack
Black's like God damn it five seconds
bro 18 and0 18
finishes no way yeah 180 18
finishes Trump trump is so upset right
now that the American
lost five seconds Wonder Boy five
seconds UFC disciplin and Wonder Boy
this gave him the worst matchup possible
they said oh you complain about pay say
less that's not right though it was the
worst matchup ever that's not that's not
right I know you know how the business
goes dog we've all been there they did
to me my last fight who was your last
fight Travis
Brown I was ranked like 13 he was three
made no sense I was like why are we
doing this oh I'm be
disciplined I don't like Travis Brown
that one bit though I know you don't I
don't have a problem with him huh why
cuz he trained one of my dogs and had
her for six months oh you said that and
then she came back dumber than when she
left oh may maybe it's he has a
different philosophy of training oh
maybe he didn't train my dog and
just took my money there's that too
that's probably more accurate I don't
have a problem with if I was heavyweight
back then I would have fought him what
what what kind of uh do you you still
have a bunch of dogs no I just got one
now the other two dogs they in heaven
now Dog Heaven All Dogs Go to Heaven dog
yeah they in heaven now I just got the
little little bitty ass dog with the
green hair damn dog dog has green hair
yeah my dog is a pimp what kind of dog
it's a little small thing it's a little
small he's a shitsu Yorkie my best
friend come sleeps in the bed with me
every night best friend he's my best
friend I I mean yeah I feel like you'd
have like a Kan Corso or something that
what that dog was that Travis Brown
train it was a Kane it was a
Kane Coro I got love my K Corso don't me
trying to my I haven't post I haven't
posted them in a while I saw it
though little shitu it's the shitu You'
be scrolling for a while you try to find
I know but no one's going to see this
anyways it's just us oh Casey has a
great dog yeah a cute dog he's a he's a
wiener dog oh those are cool dogs oh
dude it was with us all day yesterday we
drove at San Diego yesterday the dog was
chilling with us all day no that's a
cool those are cool dogs the Wier dogs
yeah I called them I called them uh
Butters I call them Butters I call them
show show BR SW my daughter though
that's who that's who I got the dog for
my daughter she's she be 17 in in a in a
um end of this month look how my
daughter can be a look at look at my
daughter can be a mod boy yeah I'm about
to change my last name
Jackson oh my God what's up daddy Circle
what up daddy
Circle that's
good that's
good she cool yeah yeah yeah she cool
all right we put the picture she getting
good grades and she's smart as hell
she good
grade what is she
into my daughter SM as that's cool
man yeah that's tough having a hot
daughter right yeah she's a good girl
though she's a good girl she she out of
all my kids she's the only one that that
kind of like listens to me and like
listens to my advice and she she's in
school yeah she's yeah she's in
school so she's half black and half
asian then right half Japanese half
Japanese she's a Japanese cool blazing
that's a cool mix no I don't like
blazing that's like they sexualize that
word really yeah F yeah it's crazy
just like it's just a mix
IX black and Asian blazian what's wrong
with cuz it's like um like when you look
up on porn yeah blaz you type in blazian
wow I don't never type that in you type
in the word you said no I'm not into
blazion you type in the word you said I
can't say I'm not I'm not I'm not into
blazion no way that's not your thing you
you want full I well no I like all girls
but but
blazion you just said all girls I like
all girls like okay look if I'm out and
I meet a hot girl you know what I'm
saying she's so happen to be blazing I'm
not going to like kick out of bed for
eating crackers I feel you damn your
that's your dog huh yeah that's my dog
but I got it for my daughter I knew he
was SE I got it for my daughter that's
why I show you my daughter on her ninth
birthday I I got that's a good gift I
got it but U her dog her dog died on her
birthday oh damn on her ninth birthday
so I got it but her mom so go how'd it
go I told her mom not to tell her her
dog died and you said ran away no her
mom told her cuz I was saving the day
with Gizmo her mom was so petty she
didn't want me to save the day damn so I
got stuck with him and that girl we was
talking about earlier she was like no
you been I was going to take him back to
the mall where I got him she said no you
better not take that dog he's the cutest
dog ever so I kept him now he's my best
friend now he's your homie he's my homie
bro if I I take him to the gym with me
if I'm sparring if people hitting me he
goes and bite their ankles he's a little
thing huh I would not I would have not
have guessed that size dog white green
well I I uh lime green is my favorite
color oh you got lime green cars yeah
like three of them three of my cars are
lime green wow I like the lime green
cars lime green that Dodge Demon 170
comes in that lime green you seen that
thing number one car I won dog that
thing is filthy what's your news yeah
your news is the Porsche you just is
that the newest one no I got a lightning
and a TRX lightning and TRX TRX yeah how
you liting the
gas it's not great wait what year is the
lightning lightning is a uh 2004 what's
the what's it is that the electric car
Google how dare you no no what the
lightning you think I changed my
pronouns got electric car come on bro no
the lightning is the old school it got
real famous and fast imperious what it
was from 1999 2004 Ford Lightning
generation 2 generation ones are dope
from two from 93 95 yeah I remember so
popular that it's ugly how dare you dog
wow that's basic that's my exact car
right there that's that's it that's ugly
400 horsepower 20 four D I'm four dog
I'm that that thing's get a Whipple
supercharger put on it if you put only
way that car look good if you put like a
body kit like a f you know flared it out
and something this a't Pimp My Ride dog
those days are over yeah those days are
done yeah Pimp My R over my ride they
don't do that to car no more man
I'm always behind the times I you know I
don't follow the
trends like what what what what's your
favorite car you have that I own right
now I don't know I'm s my Hellcat that's
my favorite car
uh just Challenger Hellcat yeah so the
the Challenger demon is the Hellcat but
with a bigger supercharger and the new
one has 1000 and I'm sorry 1,080
horsepower 0 to 6 and 1.6 why they need
that why not bro I don't trust American
cars going that fast oh but you trust
Japanese cars damn right I do yeah I bet
you do hell right yep all right I'll
tell you what I trust is happy hippo
Crum listen whatever I'm doing podcast
stand up at the gym I'm on that crom
whether you want gummies powders highly
concentrated shots they got the KPS they
got it all you can trust happy hippo
Crum and you get freaking 20% off for
life that's right it's my Hidden Gem
it's happy hippo Crum all you got to do
is go to happy hippo.com promo code is
thick 23 get 20% off for life it's the
best katum on the planet it's happy
hippo let's get back to the program yeah
your Hellcat is that uh uh green your
Hellcat lime green lime green yeah good
for you man
I never been to like the crazy color
cars that Raptor you got dope I love
Raptors we can do some things with that
Raptor if you're trying to get Frosty
with it I gu some we could do some
something fun with that Raptor now yeah
I just got that uh you know that that
Sprinter van that Mercedes oh those are
dope yeah those are dope did you pimp it
out inside oh I bought it like all the
way down all pimped out those are dope I
just recently got back from I was
talking to you I got back from up North
was my brother really yeah camping I
heard on you and I like your pot I like
your co-host she's you guys good
together there's good chemistry there
Sarah's great yeah she's how dare you
how are you married no s's relationship
he's married to the game no you're in a
relationship but not with the co-host no
is she hot is she hot she's a pretty
girl what's her name he's married to the
gym I'm married to the gym yeah married
he married some dude named Jim yeah to
the gy yeah do he he's married to Jim
full MERS don't come at me what I'm just
I'm what he said the gym oh my
oh yeah yeah yeah gum it had it's been a
while what it's been a while no no I was
in the gym I was in the gym the other
day so you were with gym the other day I
was in the gym the other day okay you
was in gym the other day no his co-host
let's see her coost no uh what's her
name
Sarah she's good because you needed a a
good co-host on there she's good man she
had me cracking on when she goes she
said it's so weird okay well yeah she's
pretty yeah
is she Persian yeah yeah yeah yeah but
cuz your brother's here right and she
was saying your brother lives in a van
is that my brother's Liv in Van for
eight years yeah I did a pod with him
recently too where where's your brother
at he's up in Mammoth right now where I
just no and like you got a picture of uh
damn yeah go to my last pod yeah he you
she he's in the thumbnail yeah she's a
pretty girl just do uh raw talk you'll
see it raw talk yeah or just go to the
YouTube real quick would you date a rip
girl like in shape and everything yeah
of course you like that yeah I mean I
don't like I don't like this is what I
want but I like a girl who works out for
sure but you like the girl with all the
ABS and six speack and stuff like that I
mean damn that's your brother right
there that's my brother right there
yeah he's not into weights and stuff
like
you
no why you what's going on with your
face just saying's different than breath
just he's a different guy that's not me
I know but you out of pocket though bro
am I that was kind of yeah the first one
was with your the first one with your
daughter that's your brother right there
out hair yeah yeah oh okay he's old or
younger a little
older okay so he's not out of he's not
he's not overweight no no don't train
okay yeah but no he's so jacked yeah
it's like you think okay the way he said
it I didn't see him yet I assumed that
your brother was probably overweighted
like you wouldn't think his brother look
like that that's all I'm saying why you
put it on that picture oh
God think of his brother like cuz he's
such a good chip you no you got the same
nose yeah no you can see you guys you
guys have like dents like mustaches and
beard like your hair yeah
yeah yeah he's he just lives in a van
down by the river he looks like he lives
in a van for real he does for the last
eight years why why because you have
like that entrepreneur like hustle and
he doesn't have that he just took a
different route man he just wasn't about
like material I appreciate that I
at this point in my life me after having
all this I like I went like
literally probably for the first time in
I don't know how many years actually
vacation stay in stay in my van he
stayed in your van no I stayed in my van
he had his van you stayed in two separ
Vans we have two separate Vans the van I
was talking about damn really but your
next to his van and Y just damn but your
Van's bie he's in like the old Ram Dodge
van no he's in a four he made it nice
but yeah mine is a little bie bie but
like I was just like you want to take a
shower dog he's like what you got a
shower on your van I got a shower on the
van did he borrow your van to take a
shower no no but he he how's he make a
living he does like construction and
like Contracting stuff he just hustles
like like uh side gigs yeah well he'll
work at like uh during the ski season he
work at like Alpine or somewhere and
then he'll do like uh construction type
stuff bro I bet he's happy as I bet
you he's happy as bro he is easier
life cuz you don't have all these
commitments he probably doesn't have
social media yeah super minimal he's
super happy is he married no you got a
girl he's super happy though I got to
take more out of you know why you
looking you know he's not married DG
what I don't know that some women like
that Bro in a van yeah you might be
right I see it on TI Tok I see on Tik
Tok girls be traveling in Vans and Stu
all the time he meet one of those people
that you know they mostly white people
you know this what like van dat but am I
right though we should create app we
should create an app like Road Life app
you just live out your car car date bro
you car date bro you owning something
bro car date car date bro you owning
something BR just a bunch of bro
stupid you tell you H something
something like you put all you all
people that live out of the cars the riv
Mammoth by the you know by the pair or
whatever meet me here I get this bro why
you saying in live people going to go
already get it right now cuz that's it's
a good idea for real you could have been
a billionaire off that one idea you
think there's that many people without
homes yeah especially now that uh uh
your your boys in office and the the
country yeah no no no no your boys oh
with Nome yeah he's cre business us with
the president we got in the economy oh
bid I know I know he's helping out car
dates yeah everyone jumping in cars yeah
yeah fck you and your brother talk a lot
he probably have service where he's at
no yeah no he got service we talk yeah
really yeah yeah what's a Verizon you
think uh I think you got AT&T cuz I
know I don't have service if he's down
by the river in a van and he has service
I need to switch he's real happy though
man like to see that it's cool to see
yeah I I admire it like they don't like
want anything and they're just content
with the van and chilling and with their
thoughts like I can't stop exactly but
you know what I'm saying you know like
us it's like it's never enough it's
exhausting and then it's like the more
you get the more you have to do to
maintain yes it's exhausting it's
different life you know different people
who's this kid
that is brand Roy Val Denver's
finest and that is fedor's little
brother behind him no that's not no it's
not looks like him though huh I've seen
that guy cuz he's a Denver cat that guy
fedor's brother looks scary as hell hell
super scary he's in prison no he's out
by now did he get out think he he did
some horrible he did some horrible
huh that was a bad boy I couldn't
even believe he did he's like Russian
mafia his tattoo on his back yeah
dude yeah he looks like it he have you
seen that movie The
Machine chryler from oh with ber crer he
goes to Russia the com yeah the B That's
my boy that's your boy that's my boy
yeah I tell him I love that movie
oh God you guys be great you got to do
his podcast you know I told that's right
I don't care know if I got something to
promote b b you would love Bert he's
funny he's great he's funny he don't do
podcast if you have something to promote
well I'm just saying like you know he
doesn't like a weekly podcast now though
yeah it's a lot of work bro yeah I do an
MMA podcast yeah I know I've seen it oh
thanks yeah thanks for watch it thanks
like subscribe like subscribe yeah of
course all right thanks how do you like
doing the podcast bro cuz you're doing
it more fulltime now I love it I love it
I have two pods once a week I have two
pod what's the other one it's the one
with me and Sarah that you were talking
about and then you that one's called
Mommy Daddy talk minees we all talk oh
dope yeah you got a fitness podcast on
there you don't not really a fitness
podcast it's more just like talking just
life current event yeah it's
good what's what people are doing I'm
going to have you on I need to have you
on all right all right yeah I need to
find something to promote promote your
podcast oh okay cuz that's the only way
to promote podcast by going another
podcast oh
okay all right why why do people do
podcast if they don't got nothing to
promote just to talk about talk
with your friends I just met this
no you met me before I knew yep
yeah yeah I met you you did it's all
good it's all good it's all
good CT you've been on the show before
my bad this our second time meeting yeah
second time all right right I no that
when we when we when I first pulled up
you were like Rampage I was like
yeah my bad I thought about
it I said I think I met this
before it's that thing you can only you
can only store about 300 names in your
head it's all good you know you know
what I think it is I I've been thinking
about this lately what I think it is I
started smoking weed when I was eight
years old and my my you think you saw
the punches of the head no no I don't
take that many punches you did though
but no I didn't you talk about somebody
got the best defense go watch my fights
no I'm going wear your defense the role
that's your but in practice you got
punched in the head do I got saying a
lot yeah yeah yeah but not not as much
as people but I was thinking about I
started smoking weed when I was 8 years
old by the time I was 11 I smoked it
every day all the way till I was 17
that's a problem especially when your
brain's developing and you're smoking
weed they say that's like the worst time
to do it yeah so I think that's probably
what was wrong with my memory and but I
chalk it up to it's easy just to tell
people yeah I think I've been punched
too many times but I think it's from you
I think it is I bet it's the combination
of both of those yeah you might be right
I think main my bad but I I'll tell you
what I remember the next time though for
sure it's fine oh bro I first time we
didn't talk that much though did we you
guys did a podcast for three hours
together we did this you had a good time
but no I was on that tle thick I got
drunk oh he got hammered yeah if I get
drunk got white girl hammered I could
have I could have robbed you you
could have robbed me a th put a thong on
he got the he don't got the right equip
he got the right right
equipment she was she was twerking on me
when right she was she that girl she
could twerk and you was just wasted
going the yeah I was wasted hey the last
thing what hotel
Cosmo the last thing I remember is her
her twerking on my
head like knocking me out she was trying
to knock me out and then when you saw
the gun were you like what are you doing
there was no gun like oh you freak no it
was no gun oh you passed out I passed
out that's why that's what it
is that's tough Man chalk it up to the
game You' had a lot of good times and
now one bad night you shouldn't ruin the
pie yeah get back in there I knew I knew
knew it was a bad idea my friend like
yeah let's go let's do this like I knew
it was a bad
idea she she's
she's drinking too much is the bad idea
both yeah both I never in Vegas I I I
never invite like strange girls up in my
room only girls I know this is my first
time I ever ever got I got got this my
first time damn first time and they got
you and they got me and just go back to
the strip club she was in give back
met no I met her at the at the at the
cosmo at the at the table I didn't go to
the strip club I you a
professional oh you got play from from
from where it go you're too old for that
man I know I was already you know the
game bro I was drunk out of my mind I
get it you understand I get it I
couldn't even pick her up in the lineup
damn I couldn't pick her out in the
lineup know your buddy
Soler yeah they saw D she could have
been anything you think she H I thought
she was in with on one of my buddies but
cuz he left he left first but on camera
is like no he he left way before damn
your buddies don't remember what she
looks like or nothing yeah I think they
remember but don't cold assassin think
your bud she probably had a wig on and
everything cuz she looked could been a
dude damn no she was no
dude no you're hammered right I ain't
never been that hammer I still can tell
I've been in Thailand I can tell I don't
care I I can tell I've been to Thailand
I can tell I can tell in person and
pictures is harder but in person you can
tell yeah Tyler that's the algebra that
is the dudes they try too hard you
ever see a girl walk in trying to switch
and they trying too hard and they look
like chin with a long with a wig trying
to hide that thing dong yeah yo Jesus
that's all they swering is that you
take that wig
off but it's crazy that listen
that's why I don't mess with girls got
all the plastic surgeries cuz you never
know you never know girls girls have no
idea that when they doing all these pla
all these things they're looking like
they have no idea yeah their
friends don't even tell them like girl
you looking kind of is girls
should tell their home girls like quit
cut back you got to cut back cuz cuz
dude's doing that and you looking
like the tranis yeah one one more chin
implant you look like Liam nce in the
girl you know what I'm saying like
that's what I'd say to my friends that
what you telling yeah you look
like yeah but but you like those girls
like Morgan Freeman yeah say to the girl
oh damn you like the girls with the fake
bus though I heard about you all around
MMA we all know about you in the fake
book I mean I mean it's very I like big
asses it's it's you know I'm not yeah
you cannot lie that's my No that's my
thing but but you'll take a girl with a
fake ass you don't care I mean
technology is so Advanced now man when
they do the the Lipo and they put in the
asset the BBL yeah it's BBL don't count
for you the BBL don't count huh I don't
care you don't care I don't like the
implants feels different imps are weird
it feel don't feel good how you ever
smash your girl with a BBL what about
implants probably I mean probably it
could have been both one or the other
implants are old school though yeah it's
an old school it's like we with
you know look new Xbox you remember how
Kim K's ass used to look back in the day
like a big diaper yeah like Dum she got
it redone huh
yeah yeah I've never smashed a girl with
a fake ass or BBL that I know of it's
not it's not it that's how good it was
you didn't even know I'mma ask kosu I
think I could tell you would tell I'mma
ask
conosur you tell you could always tell
it's like harder it's kind of weird a
BBL I I think that socer is it's fat
cells yeah it's fat so it's it's it's
hard to tell cuz it's the placement is
weird you have like high up on their
back all right I don't know I don't know
NE I don't know neither one of
these oh damn cut out with fire I
know either neither one of these dudes
oh man panta yeah Pantoja had a great
fight against Brandon Moreno what's his
weight what's his weight this is
flyweight okay yeah it's a good fight
they fought before and Pantoja beat uh
royell they're so fast by submission
they're so fast so talented this fight
just got overshadowed because they're
you know the flyweights and there's so
much fire on the rest of the card which
one fought um Brandon Melo uh Brandon
Moreno Pia beat which the right P the
guy in the black he's the he's from
Brazil oh he the champ he's the champ
and he won the belt he gets on the mic
starts crying goes are you proud of me
now dad like this is deep he said in
English or Portuguese uh English
otherwise I wouldn't understand you know
I would understand they could have
translated for you I thought you said
he's from Brazil yeah but he he that
part of English he wanted he wanted
everyone to know he had a shitty dad oh
so he got a shitty Dad yep he proud of
me now dad right crying then we have to
look in the story of course UFC Ram with
the story his dad left him and his you
know his brothers and sisters when a
kid now now his son's champ what's up
now Dad yeah did did his dad ever come
back and say like hey that might be in
his corner I don't know what the hell's
going
on I thought you looked into the story
you know I'm always they didn't follow
up dog his dad might be Jack Black for
all I know bro don't never tell me the
story I always want to know like the
conclusion yeah he still a shitty dad
there's a conclusion yeah damn you don't
just dip out on your son for 25 years
then jump back in no damn 25 years you
just got to hope these flyweights don't
go 25 minutes
man yeah they're so talented though it's
tough oh and they're scrapping but
Brandon's from Denver so I go for uh Ro
looking up 10 yeah oh
damn Trump has no idea what he's looking
at sometimes I feel like 50 Cent with
his relationship with his son I got a
son that's a
damn how you put on my blast
like that the one I know vegan yeah
listen think veggies yeah listen my dad
called me today and your dad did yeah my
dad called me today and he asked me like
what's going on with you and your son I
heard you put him out stuff like that
blah blah blah I put him out but he's
living in my other house which is better
than the training house we we living in
I'm like man he's doing good he's living
at my other house he probably sleeping
in my room and and uh yeah it's not you
he's homeless put in a my other kids and
my ex-wife yeah he's in a bigger house
and and and he and so my dad asked he I
talked to him he told me this and my son
just flat out Li on me yeah like wow
like you where did he go south for
you well uh I just I just got tired of
him not listening to me like he he
begged me to go pro and he lost his his
first pro fight because because he
wouldn't lose his weight he was he had
to cut 30 lbs 20 days out damn that's a
hor it won't listen it won't listen to
me and you know how to c wait you're big
ass but I I told him 12 weeks before oh
this up told no I'm saying like
like you're big like you're not like a
small guy I'm just saying he should
listen to his Dad how's that
no he's brilliant as cutting weight if
anybody he should listen to his dad on
cutting weight but but I told him 12
weeks before his fight like look you got
to start running in the morning doing
your training then run at night to get
your weight down you do that you do that
for like four or five weeks and then you
don't have to do the running twice a day
cuz it's your fault back to one yeah cuz
he he want to fight a 55 wouldn't listen
to me damn and a lot a lot of things he
just wouldn't listen to me like I don't
know what the I'm talking about
yeah I know that's frustrating yeah I
said Son you can't be a vegan and be a
fighter and then but I gave up on it he
he still fixate on there I said said do
what you want do yeah he's going to
learn the hard way he going to learn
hard so is he still going to fight I
don't know he he he he didn't want the
manager I got him he he didn't want the
the contract I got him at the UFL you
know what it sounds like it sounds like
he needs to do his own thing that's what
I do tough love get the out of my
house that's that the message he sending
he's like listen you did it your way I
want to do it my way right it's 23 but
the deal was he would train stay clean
and listen to my toage and I would pay
all his pay for everything he have to
work that's a fair deal yeah what the
that's a bon that's a great deal he
couldn't and he couldn't keep his in the
bar so I said all right son I gave him a
couple chances I brought him a I brought
him a Mercedes SUV again this sounds
like a good deal wow yeah and
the same day I brought him a car I gave
him I gave him a car and I had him take
one of my home girls she wanted to go
somewhere do something he cussed her out
I bet you someone else is going to say
the same you said to him at some
point he's going to listen to that
person no he swear I bet 5 years from
now he's going to look back like damn I
wish listen to my dad it's just though
it's it's just in his blood to Rebel you
know yeah he just he just um he's very
entitled yeah that's one of the problems
too being your son you know he'll
learned the hard way I got a cousin that
that that fights I put I put my energy
in him is he good yeah I watched him
fight one time he he's good he got some
good coaches and stuff but he can be he
can be he can be better he can be really
he's a he's a natural athlete it has the
hard for it it's about the heart yeah he
has the heart for it you got have the
drive he has a he's tough his name is
bad time bad time that's his nickname
I'm not mad at that bad time he was a
little kid he was a little kid when I
left Memphis and he he got married he
lived up he lived up in near Palm
Springs somewhere how old is he uh he
might be he might be older than my he
probably like 25 27 up in there so still
young enough for you do something yeah
but he's been he's been training he
knows he knows a little his name Tevin
Brown Tevin teevin badtime Brown damn
that sounds nice yeah that's my
grandmother's maid name brown brown damn
yeah bad time bad
time yeah your your son to come back
around you still love him you know got
to give him that tough love yeah that's
him right there the left yeah that's my
cousin right
there my little cousin he listens to me
I tell him like yeah son you know come
train if your dad's Rampage Jackson yeah
listen you listening if it's about Flat
Earth I'm probably not listening but if
it comes to fighting I'm listening hey
you know the thing about me with comes
to picking up hookers in the room I
don't push I'm not list I can't even
even I believe I can't stand when people
pushing on other people you know the one
thing about Flat Earth that does trip me
out Google uh images of
satellites do it literally that images
yeah be like satellite type in a
satellite just like type in Satellite
like you'll see no the moon landing's a
little weird you'll see no there's all
like they're just all there's no real
pictures they're all Graphics yeah dude
dude not a single one is not this is the
one thing that Tri me out I'm not going
to lie they're all just like renders why
true why do you
think this is the one I'm gonna say this
is the one thing that trips me out I've
never seen a satellite that was real I'm
just saying I'm not a flat Earth thr I'm
just saying yeah that is very strange
now that you bring that up here's my
thing why would they want to sell us on
Earth being round what's the benefit the
sun's clearly round the moon's clearly
round so Earth is just in the same
solar system and we're we're the only
flat
Planet yall stupid right no no no listen
this I don't want to get into this
debate with you cuz you I'm not debating
that's legit question like we're the
only flat Planet why would they why are
they selling us on round cuz it's not
only just it's not the that's not the
only thing they selling you on they
selling you on space as well that's why
you thinking like that cuz you thinking
out of space and all those other planets
and stuff yeah huh you don't you don't
think they're real
you don't think Sun's real no no no sun
is real the Sun and the Moon is real
okay but out of space it's not yeah
because we haven't se then what is it
what are we it's water over the
firmament is
water over the firmament he's talking
we're in the ocean right now we under
the firmament Under the Dome and there
water over the firmament firmament says
it in the
Bible there out of space is there's no
such thing there's no such thing as out
of space no and that's the whole thing
that get got you tricked in why you
think the other planets and stuff the
planets are wondering stars that you
think so you think all all that like
them going to Mars stuff is all uh how
they going to the Mars why they don't
put the same Rover on the moon so we can
watch the earth spin right now how they
going to go to Mars we're talking about
building a society on Mars right yeah
how they why they doing that why they
ain't got the same thing on the moon
right now though yeah how they go how
they going go to Mars like the whole
thing is like we never went back to the
Moon right why not yeah I know yeah I
don't want to get in that debate because
I'm just it's entertaining I know it's
me but this is the thing this is
why this above my I'm tell you why I
don't want to give it to cuz some of my
close friends there the only ones have
conversations with and the and their
comebacks to me about the stuff I and I
know I I know why they have such a
closed mind because I was just like that
you want you want to know what what what
changed me to to actually go back to the
Bible research and believe in Flat Earth
that hooker that robbed you no the she
wasn't a hooker for one she was she a
high class high class guess what bro
I'mma tell you something I would not pay
for I'm not saying you did I won't
pay for you got robbed for it
though no no no no uh I want I like I
like strippers I don't like hookers yeah
real talk I I ain't no shame in my game
no I'm with you I won't I won't pay for
I won't pay for a hook you pay for lab
dance but that's it no I don't even like
lab dance I like to see him twerk y word
they I don't want to touch I go to
actually any of my friends go club with
me I don't get dance yeah but what were
we going to say about oh this is what
this is what this is what this is what
changed me when um I I looked into um
emergency
Landings simp something simple as that
that's what changed me to go more to
like oh yeah then I went to the Bible
and start reading with the Bible and you
know I used to be a Christian so I like
oh I've read this stuff before but you
don't we think of of a different I went
there now I look at the Old Testament
like a history book and so I went and
read and like a history book I was like
oh okay that broke it broke everything
down for me but if you look into
whenever you have time just look into
emergency Landings and do you mean by
emergency landing like when like when
say somebody's flying from Asia coming
to LA and like if it's an emergency or
something and then see like the way they
land then you going to think like you
think like wow that that's not an emerc
land they went all the way out the way
and then you got to break down why did
they did did they do that why they go
all the way out the way they say it's
emergency landing that that's what
changed my mind why would they go all
the out of the way exactly that's Point
ex exactly but but but why would that
prove that there's this flat if you go
out of the way cuz if it was an
emergency a real emergency weren't you
go somewhere closer when you go
somewhere closer and not somewhere out
of the way you saying since it's flat
they go out of the way no no no no no no
no no no no no no on the globe when we
see the emergency landing on the globe
it don't make sense oh cuz it CU it's
like this yeah so it's farther it's
farther away so common sense would tell
me that we're we're being lied to about
the geography of of our things why lie
to us about the the Earth being round
though that's the big question I think
it has to do with religion but I'm not
going to get into this whole
conversation no it is deep conversation
yeah it is interesting all all it when
you think about taxes like all the all
just our system in general the
government like and all that stuff it
you're just like is it will almost
stretch you out so much
not much you can do bro this is the last
thing I'm going say and I'm going watch
this fight look look up when we went to
space to see Earth for the first time
then look up Universal Studios their
logo when when was that made and and
that should help you then research stuff
on your own like I don't care who who
knows the truth or who believes this or
who believes that I don't care any way
yeah I don't either but but if you're
curious look up look up when Universal
Studios made their logo and what their
logo is and then when was the first time
it is also interesting we know more
about our o or we know more about they
say space than we do our own ocean right
my question is always like why right
like why would it be that way
yeah yeah it's deep for sure damn his
hair looks like a
bird but I say it think they well they
going to hear you still probably they
won't hear me no I'm saying this they'll
hear you if you say it now yeah hear I
can hear you yeah what you trying to do
like if you if you say something now
this doesn't hear you I'm just letting
you know what you trying to say trying
I'm just I don't know why you're scared
of talking about it if that's your truth
and it's flat dog let us know say no cuz
cuz I just I just see I just see had
have my friends like some of my friends
when it comes up and stuff like that I I
don't push it on people when it comes up
I and they ask me I just say how I feel
and some people get mad some people get
really angry because that's what they're
taught it's the same thing if you with
religion like you're like how do you
know there was Jesus well you got to
have faith they get upset cuz that's
their you know that's how they're raised
so you're going against their values and
traditions challenging
something it goes so deep like if
challenge you know what government like
all that whole system yeah cuz it's been
around for years crazy insan it's
taxes are crazy nuts dude nuts
how much money does NASA make a year off
taxes balling balling and also you look
at who started NASA you know the Nazis
that stuff the operation paper what's
his name we're getting to DS D Sam
tripley come on out things man yeah
operation paper clip's crazy man
operation B oh get
started God damn it it's fun though you
know whether it's true or not it's fun
it's funner than the true you know
what's going to be really funny though
that clip of him talking about that is
going to go viral no on to I know it
is Mark it down fellas I know it
is uh you think with the hit talking
Flat Earth 100% no I don't no it's a big
movement right mark my word hey a lot of
people a lot of people are waking up to
it now mark my words interesting
some people said that Elon mus knows and
he that's why he's doing what he's doing
because he's showing stuff oh that's he
would be the type of guy to do that he's
sh CU he knows he can't come out and be
like yo I know it's because people like
you're an idiot so he's like all right
I'm G show you yeah cuz you know when
they when they launch rockets they
always go over the curve yeah but I
heard I don't know I haven't pay
attention but his leg going straight up
and no Rockets none National rockets
that go straight up they don't never go
straight they always go to the curb and
they said the reason why they do that
cuz the Earth is spinning so they go
around curve the sight the the the
explanations are so stupid and we
believe it it's just it's so ingrained
you know cuz your parents were taught
that their parents were taught that so
if you go against no no our grandparents
actually our grandparents wasn't taught
that you're you're your your great our
grandparents our grandparents and our
great-grandparents was taught that the
Earth was flat before before
1968 I don't think so look find
encyclopedia before 1968 a dude I'd have
to ask my dad but I don't think my
grandpa thought that yeah your grand
maybe your grandparents parent maybe
your great- grandparents find a
encyclopedia before 19 before find a
encyclopedia go to school with black
people dude yeah it's like a different
time hey hey we was hey we was glas lit
when when they told us that Christopher
Columbus thought the Earth was flat they
was glass they was glass lighting us
then they were gas gasl but also
glasslight they also gas I like glassl
but no they were gaslighting us when
they said Columbus found America yeah
that ran in the Bahamas right yeah
the Vikings like he thought he was he
was for India that's why we call n
Native American Indians and come on and
we going to trust our educational and
you going to take Columbus Day Away bro
that's up man a lot of indigenous
people don't like that so
but why cuz cuz we haven't we wasn't
taught everything that he did though he
did some up and but we
wasn't everyone did that but the Indians
also did up things that's what
they did back then yeah but we Savage
days but we don't we don't have we don't
have a holiday about that though there's
Native American awareness month but it
ain't holiday about them up
other and scapp
ain't scapp day no
scalping yeah scalping am I saying that
word wrong too no I I know where you
were going with it yeah yeah the
indigenous people they know a lot of
because their history get passed down
you yeah big time but the Indians
thought the Earth was flat or Native
Americans thought a lot a lot of other
civilization old civilization thought
that uh they think the Earth is they
thought it was um flat with the with the
with the dome in there wouldn't it be
nice to know can we get a freaking
answer in 2024 for God sake can we just
stop messing around playing grab ass and
get up there man would it be nice to get
this going I know but to just solve
things yeah a lot of would go lot
can Hillary Clinton just take her mask
off and be a lizard for God's sakes am I
right can we see that list dude oh D oh
dude you talking about the the journal
the journal yeah that list and we just
can't get it can we see L not one name
gets released can we see that what's up
with that crazy man that's crazy that's
crazy a lot of people think I've seen a
lot of people think ep's alive oh he
killed himself he's out he's dead don't
know you can't tell what's true and
what's false now because Photoshop and
all and CGI so good now all sorts of
stuff and now we got AI but think about
the the government's been hustling this
for since JFK days that whole warn thing
like all all that was complete
trash trash until the res recruiter
Reser whatever film came
out what is it zud zuder yeah which was
released by a comedian he released it it
went to Heraldo Rivera he released on
his show that was 10 years after
assassination they're like hold up why
does that go back and that's when people
were like no no and the multiple people
out that scene were like there was
multiple
shots even back then they were hustling
us figure it out bro easier back then to
hustle for
sure now now it's pretty easy too though
with like Ai and and social media like
you can you can create a movement like
the anti-semitic movement like on Tik
Tok where if you if you post this it
increases your followers your view so
they push you to post this type of
content like figure it out have you seen
the videos of Joe Rogan talking about
his AI yeah yeah you really selling
product yeah if yeah if you're not
really paying attention you think it's
Joe Rogan saying Brian's buddy bought a
sleep out thing and thought it was
Rogan's bro that's real but but a lot of
people could be tricked a lot of you
know what they found out that most uh uh
humans most of us we're sheep we are oh
I could have told you that yeah pic
showed that yeah yeah yeah so we are so
they know this so a lot of that's what
we just livestock and we buy we we're
consumers so they can trick us do this
well look at cell phones like the the
way it's set up is it's a sheet
mentality you get on there you click
like this for hours we're already
zombies this made us zombies we're
zombies I'm guilty of it that's a choice
though yeah but it's built to be
addictive you know yeah yeah so it's
come with a general surgeon W it's going
to be so addictive yeah it's not good
you see the thing that where that they
they put that machine on that guy's head
and he they it like reads his thoughts
is that the Elon uh thing yeah is he
still doing this no no not the
neuralink this is just some some other
device some some AI that this guy has on
cuz I don't think he's audible but he's
he could think and he's able to just DOD
just like pop up does it say like
Stephen Hawkins like is it talking like
Stephen Hopkins updated I didn't see it
but what I saw was it's just like words
on a screen like his thoughts are out on
do like just from him thinking it's
weird it was like how is it
tapping into your yeah the world
consious the weird the world weird I'm
scar I'm scared I'm scared of um I'm
scared I'm scared of I'm scared of
everything also AI haven't seen
Terminator you idiots we know
how this goes when when Mark Zuckerberg
set up they they had two AI talking to
each other they had to unplug it because
it started goes the the humans are
listening us talking code they talk
about taking over Zuber like he was like
pull the plug he's making some like
hundred million doll like uh underground
bunker in Hawaii oh is he like now to do
Jiu-Jitsu I don't know yeah probably
what happened with what happened with
him Elon fight I think they were just
just hype I feel like
I I think they I think they really don't
like each other because of Twitter and
and and no you know what is they're B
they're billionaires they've done
everything like let's let's have
something to do let's fight we're
billionaires neither one us can really
hurt each other we both built like
let's just fight each other like his
punch isn't going to hurt that actually
Elon he's big man no Zucker knows dude
Elon to use Joey words uh Joey Diaz's
words he has that immigrant mentality
he's from South Africa dude Mark
Zuckerberg went to Harvard so cuz Elon
mus is an African-American you just
going to just gonna automatically just
say like absolutely yeah CA he's
immigrant mentality dude and he's bigger
but he don't know Jiu-Jitsu though he
they do neither does Zuckerberg he he
does tournaments and stuff yeah is he
white I played chess twice I don't know
chess you feel me I know he does some
stuff but you know are you good at
Jiu-Jitsu I'm actually not bad I just
don't like it that much yeah I don't
like it people don't people don't know
how good my jiujitsu is you have to be
get all those years training like
working on defense and stuff you know
how many black belts I beat in fights a
ton yeah but you knock them out you
didn't submit them well I don't want to
submit them but I I've beat him and in
I've done had to do Jiu-Jitsu with him
in a fight they didn't submit me I'm
aware I I know Jiu-Jitsu yeah I just
don't show it you would have to yeah you
want it that was actually that was
actually the second martial art that I
learned I was a wrestler then I learned
Jiu-Jitsu from faban eha no damn the
king of
Umba yeah you being in the game that
long you're pick it up yeah a lot of
people surprised that I know
Jiu-Jitsu I put the Jew in Jiu-Jitsu oh
damn I don't think you're like Gordon
Ryan but I knew you knew you're how' you
do that what put the Jew in jiu-jitsu
man we all
Jews we're getting deep man this is deep
Flat Earth flat Earth juw we're not
supposed to talk about this on this on
the fight compan why not talk about
whatever we want oh we can you heard me
and Rogan Eddie Bravo on comp goes Ed go
you want you want conspiracy like you
want talk about someone has their m
doctorate in conspiracies him and Sam
tripley will blow your mind where you're
like okay I guess what about Alex Jones
they got him back on Twitter you saw
that crazy I'm going tell you I'm going
to tell you about Eddie Bravo I like
Alex I'm tell you about I'm going tell
you about Eddie Bravo I I believe Eddie
Bravo knows a lot about the Flat Earth n
and stuff but he knows all of it but but
the way he delivers it it makes it like
he sounds like he crazy but that's just
like he's an Ecentric he's an inet guy
but but that's my opinion that's my own
person that's like Trump right like he
he like if you're a Trump a fan of trump
it's like his intentions and and what
the message he's trying to get we it' be
better if it's more political but he's
so like harsh and entertaining people
are like this guy's they you know they
can't stand it I don't think Eddie's
like that Eddie's so entertaining and
he's an Entertainer like Eddie's a
musician he's a creative you know he
came up with uh jiujitsu Eddie Bravo's
whole you know system so he's a
Entertainer so he delivers it as that
Entertainer so it's it's weird cuz he
knows his I just know when when I
first that he's smart bro I I know when
I first came across the Flat Earth stuff
I didn't believe in and stuff and and I
was trying to debunk it and everything
the thing that that that threw me off
was they were talking about how fast the
Earth spins at 666 everything 666 and
stuff like that and making it sound like
so evil and that's that's the thing that
threw me off I'm like you know that's
too much of a conspiracy like I know
people can be smart and suff and and be
EV I know how evil this world is because
I'm a very spiritual person yeah and and
I I know the true meaning I know the
true reason why they're lying I do and
but that that stuff is is that that's
what threw me off about the whole Flat
Earth and and I didn't believe the only
time the only way I believed it I came
across the emergency landing thing
that's when I was like yeah I look into
it I'm pretty open-minded but I'm
skeptical if that makes sense yeah like
you tell me something I'll like d you're
crazy and then tonight I go home and
look I'm like all right I'll text you
later like damn you see this well I'm
still not fully on board but I'm at
least I won't shut it down I won't shut
anything down you know what he said
about the satellites is what he say he's
100% through and uh we got gas lit again
when U one of the satellites um dropped
one of one of the satellites and the
media saw cuz we got all these cell
phones they told us it was a Chinese spy
balloon oh that's right they were saying
they were spy balloons they said they've
been up there forever though that's
that's that's satellites they are
satellites those are satellites with the
balloons yeah that's those are
satellites interesting that's what a
satellite really looked like Yeah It's
just tough to know what's like the more
like with social media like and people
that are in the know and like when the
like uh Edward Snowden came out when
he's like they're watching all your
all and you're like what and he like had
that special clearance and the more you
find out and then the zinski and Ukraine
and the money we're sending them that we
can't give Hawaii money it's like what
your
taxes but the problem is like you can
uncover all this stuff and look into it
there here's and this is the problem you
can't do about it no nothing that's
the problem like even with like the
voting stuff like I don't even know if
when it comes down to voting it's like I
don't know if my vote counts I heard it
D that's what I heard too who knows yeah
who knows so it's like no they want this
guy in for this reason to push this
agenda cuz he's part of this party and
they can control him you're like what is
happening I mean you'd be crazy to think
that all the most powerful richest
people in the world aren't all kind of
doing this and you got to be crazy
to think that they're all honest and
they're going to tell us the truth about
everything oh no why would they why
would yeah it's it's it's just like with
the pandemic the way they're control
people and then I you know I I was proud
of America I was like there's no way
America it's our blood to Rebel there's
no way people can go along with this I
hit the street I'm like oh no that's the
first time they hit me like oh man this
is real they but but think about how
many people got the uh vaccine shot
because they were scared to lose their
jobs and stuff so I think a lot of
people went along with it just that's
different yeah they I'm talking about
the people like still it's 2023 December
and they're still in mask I'm like they
they they brainwashed you so bad bro and
I I feel sorry for this like they brain
watch you so bad you're still this
scared man I saw one of Chan's cousins
and his auntie in in in a car no driving
driving by herself with the mask on a
couple weeks ago like a couple months
ago that's insane with a mask on the
front and the back bro what the but
why you going to drive in your car even
then even in the M midst of it why you
going to drive in your car along with a
mask on I saw a dude drive by himself in
the car with the windows up with a mask
that's what I'm talking about that's
what I'm just saying you know what he's
driving what
Tesla think about it bro I don't know
man the people
losing their mind I that's why I
didn't understand I hated that damn mask
when you got Weir on the airplane I
hated that damn mask and then it just
doesn't matter now then then then your
boy uh your boy Alex Jones was saying
they're trying they're going to try and
bring it back and do the mail and B
ballots thing because when you think
about the way it lined up with the mail
and ballots because they they knew they
were going to lose again to Trump so
they to figure out so then it's mail and
ballots you what's about racism when
they went no no black people don't have
licenses so they have to mail it in
you're like that's the most racist
I've ever heard right wa who said that
the Democrats have do mailing because
it's not fair it's racist because black
people don't have licenses they don't
have said that all the left that's
how they pushed it they said they said
it's racist cuz they should be able to
mail it and we're making it too tough
for them to show licenses and proof of
you know identification that's
gaslighting that's the most racist thing
yeah I never I never met a a black
person over 18 that didn't have a driver
license I've never met a black or white
person that didn't have a license
yeah it's not even a thing it's not a
thing you have like they're like yeah
bro of course I do I'm tell you
something you know racist I just assume
they can't no this is It's really
up cuz do you know how much trouble you
get into for being black and not having
ID if the police pull your inwhere and
you got no ID you know what happened to
you black or white well I'm I don't know
I never been white before so I can just
tell you well I'm just saying but if you
get pulled over you have no license I'm
talking about you have no proof no no no
I'm not talking about driving oh you
just talking about just out out walking
anywhere they pull you they stop you ask
you for your driver license ID
hassle yeah you as a black person yeah I
bet I'm telling you black people we have
our we know what happened to us but
in general like how racist is that to
assume you guys don't have it but
but it's also like with the college
system they're like no we got to we got
to make it easier for them to get to
Harvard because they can't do the same
as Asians or Jewish or white people
you're like that's so racist yeah that
you don't think they can qualify as as
much as the other ethnicities that's the
definition of racism you think you basic
tell us you think they're stupid without
saying they're stupid poor kids are just
as smart as white kids yeah he what the
it's insane dude it's like this is
the most racist I've ever seen bro
we're living in a weird ass time movie
it's like a weird ass movie but
but there's but now there's information
available and there's people with a lot
of power like Rogan like Alex J A lot of
people out there spitting some truths
spitting some facts going against the
grain and what they try to do they try
to silence those people yeah some of
them are on silence you can't silence
you they tried to cancel tried to go for
him the thing was crazy but that's what
they do they go oh my God this guy's
getting to bit shut him down
remember they could have suit oh my God
and then that doctor came on show and he
lit him up that's what I'm saying you
don't want to debate Joe Rogan he lit
that doctor up lit him up so crazy why
is Joe Roan so so smart is it because he
always high he's interested in
everything he has he's he just has so
many interest you know cuz I think I
think when I used to smoke weed as a kid
I think I used to be I used to think I
was real intelligent I be I can like
debate and talk about a whole bunch of
when I when I used to smoke weed I
I wouldn't shut up interesting Aderall
is like that for me for real I never
tried I never done anything but
weed so I don't know weed see we I think
weed some people opens your mind you get
really creative and can get stuff done
then some people just shut you down I
just got really hungry and laughed a lot
it was not productive weed is not the
same no more now they got all these
chemicals now they
was crazy shro I like shrooms yeah
shrooms are cool to that's like the IT
thing right now I've been hearing good
things about it help you especially
especially if you if you're as you say
punch drunk I've heard some stuff about
it I probably I probably still won't try
it never try it think this flat and you
won't try
really they go hand it's peanut butter
and jelly even even like a small mic not
like a I probably try like a gummy a
chocolate a little a little micos you
don't even feel it I I just don't like I
just don't like I won't try it
uh alcohol was my was my thing and and I
and I smoke I'm I'm I'm addicted to
nicotine oh me too I hate it I
hate I'm I'mma quit again soon though do
want you get you get those are better it
don't make you tired when you train huh
no these are great taste great but how
your wife like you be kissing her with
that n man take it out I'm not that
big of a n take do you spit it in front
of her and stuff no this you this you uh
no you
swallow
God you guys are so dumb just so
funny oh he's a
swallower God damn we haven't even
commentated these fights man it's the
comain event the flyweights but it looks
like panto is doing work although Roy
Val's picking up there panta does get a
little tired these little guys it's a
great fight too yeah it's tough these
guys got overshadowed just because the
card was so fire and cuz we're talking
about Flat Earth and you know this is
going you know at least four rounds
other fights were quick yeah real quick
besides the Tony Patty one oh so it's
over it's over now is that it yeah did
they give the decision already not yet
he looks sad he looking like he feel
like he didn't do enough it's going to
be tough for him to get back there too
all that division yeah I didn't think
the little guys get tired cuz they just
keep moving they go yeah they're like
freaking
hummingbirds crazy
man yeah it's crazy in schools now they
don't even teach about Christopher
Columbus they don't teach about Malcolm
X they stopped cursive
writing they don't teach cursive writing
why the did they make us learn that
then well we we didn't have all this
technology now like we're older so you
kind of but like now like you when I got
to write like some some like God
dog my hair is terrible now cuz you
don't do it really anymore like also
calculators or like math my son was like
Dad don't phones and even my watch has a
yeah
why am I doing this I'm like cuz it's
problem solving like you need to figure
out a problem and get to the and you
know the right answer you don't want to
just rely on machines I guess that makes
sense I feel like school is just all
learning how to jump through hoops it's
all about learning how to pass tests is
is is it's all about passing tests and
not really not really memorizing you
know it's just memorizing like you know
like dates and you know yeah but it's
you really don't learn the concept of
like teach us how to like buy a house
teach us about taxes teach us about
paying bills teach us life lessons bro
you bro keep talking keep thinking you
almost you you almost are fully awake
school is not about what what we think
it's about it's a business it's a
business and it's also it's a it's like
it's a it's no different than a chicken
coop what's the first thing they teach
you about in school what's the first
thing they what's the first thing you
remember seeing when you walk inside a
classroom as a kid no he's going there
the talk about the world what's the
first thing you see oh he's going there
still going there Mrs famar was big tits
when I was inth grade what the first
thing you think what was the first thing
you think a globe glob a globe I knew
you was going there yeah no no no you
almost there with the school they no the
Earth it's it's to keep this going it's
to keep going the whole school system is
not what we think it is I'm going to
homeschool my son tomorrow tomorrow you
be dumb as hell with me it's it's the
whole school system they make you line
up and get in order get used to being
told what to do sit down well my teacher
called me they're like hey son's and I
was so proud of him he did not get in
trouble I took him to Target to get his
favorite toy cuz teacher called me he
was like your son's the only one when we
say do this he ask why I went hell yeah
my wife's like no this is bad they're
upset went no no I said it's good that's
good cuz he's down to do it but you got
to explain to him why this is perfect
like he's very stubborn like this is
perfect he was born like that this is
perfect yeah that's good school's not
school that's why it's to get you in
line keep you in line keep you in line
work at 9 to5 pay your taxes keep the
machine going what the school bu
look like big yellow mine was short but
yeah yeah I'm sure but big yellow bus
what the prison bus looks like same
samean prison food school foodis
cafeteria everything it's the same it's
the same you get you get 30 recess same
same
people you're almost there keep looking
keep looking keep looking to the school
keep looking to the school and what they
and figure out what the school objective
what do you do you know what I'm saying
like you already said you homeschool
your kids no I don't very nice I'm
saying you saying what do you do I know
you home that's a that's a that's like a
I sound like Kanye West right now if I
ever have if I have any more kids that's
what that's what's going to happen now
that I know what's going on that's what
I'm doing if I have any more kids I'm
homeschooling for sure well I got I
didn't get an argument the doctor was
cool but you know I had a baby girl
recently they're going to get a vaccine
I oh what's that for say it's hepatitis
I said I don't see any resting Nails
around here where did she get hepatitis
from why you giving that to she's a
newborn her immune system shouldn't she
build her naturally and when she's older
V I'm not antiva but that would make
more sense but hepatitis where she get
it from I don't see is there Rustin na
in here yeah is there a prostitute in
here that's the only way you get
Hepatitis that makes no sense oh no no
not happening they all right you got to
sign this waiv I'll sign whatever you
want it ain't
happening smart move though
yeah y control it's all about control
Rober Lawler the legend did you hear
about those protesters in New York
somebody got ran over didn't it well no
they're protesting and they stopped the
UFC bus they start bang they're about to
break the windows of the bus they didn't
realize it was Robbie Lawler Jamal like
all badass UFC fighters and Robbie la
they protesting UFC no they're
protesting like Gau or whatever they're
causing issues and they stopped like
they just got the bus was trying to make
and they stopped them they started like
rock the bus and they didn't realize it
was a UFC bus and Robbie Lawler goes it
because you know Jamal H everyone's like
oh my God like freaking out and Robbie L
was like control yourself we need your
energy cuz those doors open we're going
to need it he's like we're about to go
to war they better pray to God those
doors don't open to beat up all these
civilians oh some woke dude like
guys go just a right hand from Robbie
Lawler and Jamal Hill I wish those doors
would open do you do you think uh
protesting actually like work and stuff
like that when well just just just just
last night I'm driving back in San dieo
me and Casey traffic's so bad took four
hours whatever I'm with my kid Casey's
with me his cute little dog is a good
time and the TRX right got some Alcon
breaks on it shout out to them and King
shocks so we're driving back right
traffic's 4 hours I'm like what the
going on protest protesters uh
protested right where LAX is at so all
the traffic backed up to the 405 what
were they protesting they want to cease
fire in Gaza do you think that causing
issues in La is going to do anything in
Gaza you morons now you might
have a right idea and we don't want
anybody to die but do you think doing
that here in America does anything over
there all it is for them to check boxes
going look at me I'm righteous look at
me that's all it is all those mov look
at me look at me I care about people
over here but they don't do anything
that's all that is it's just a
distraction what what what I I I want to
think what's the best thing to do should
they go to Gaza and protest over there
cuz this is the thing go over there go
over there yeah those people that want
to complain about America all stuff go
to Russia let me know how it goes for
you you think it's so bad here go to
Russia right now go to Ukraine go to God
those are problems that's how good
America is we're fighting over pronouns
and all this it's a distraction
we're fighting de left and right it's
all a distraction because then they're
doing this over here hey look over here
so look over here it's a situation
though because at the end of the day
like how do you not that situation
specifically but how do you actually
make the world a better place or is it
just damned because of you got
to do something but I I don't think
causing American SES you know for in
their flights and stuff is going to what
what what are they what are they going
to do like damn I missed my flight to
Orlando well if I would just donate to
Gaza like I don't those problems are so
big yeah and the the it's a government
issue to to you know and I don't know
funding I don't know what it is I don't
know the that's way above my pay grade I
don't know the answer but I know causing
traffic for tons of people that are I'm
saying like that are 20,000 miles away
probably isn't the smartest thing it's
like when there's the protest for BLM
it's like and it's all white people BL
and they're do doing all this damage and
there's the Looting it's like hold on
what's this for again
yeah yeah we those businesses aren't
racist what's this for again why are you
doing this none of it made sense to me
yeah now I'm going too deep now I'm no
no no that's very interesting I just got
questions well that's the the big the
big question is like if it's all
right if it's all just about money
control and IND indoctrinating people
and making them fall in line then like
how do you actually change it when the
reality is like we can change it you can
know change it now have your son you
know homeschool him do whatever but at
the end of the day like the big picture
is going to keep going exactly yeah so
how so what the we because the
majority and that will never change
because right now if we told everyone yo
don't pay taxes they couldn't put
everyone no but they couldn't put
everyone in prison you couldn't well you
know the IRS is in a government it's not
part of the governmental BR IR you ever
l it's not but I'm just saying like you
could if everyone at the same time was
like yeah we're all not going to do this
just it just would not happen obviously
right cuz you got so many look the look
at the the lockdowns I assumed Americans
were go no hell no what I did and then
nothing Happ that's what you did you
paid a penalty for it right yeah yeah
that's what I did but if everybody did
that during I kept it open the whole
time you kept your gym open that's how
that's how me and Brad became friends
that's how I met him yeah you got you
got a lot of fines and so y went to
court eight times and then dropped it
they dropped they dropped it oh why cuz
they have no ground to stand on right it
was there's not what's the argument
right now especially now the science you
had to spend a lot of money yeah on L
did you get that did you recruit that
from them you couldn't sue them for
wasting your money what are you going to
do good luck suing State of California
yeah some people do it don't they they
do it yeah if they like uh wrongful you
know accusation get put in prison or
something which is I mean but
at the end of the day like it's my point
is like what what can you do then just
do what you can do on your own and the
mass like you got to remember th those
politicians on that stuff
maybe 100 of them how many people how
many how what is it 300 600 million is
in America we're the majority yeah the
military's on our side the cops are on
our side we have all the power but
people don't realize that we have all
the power yeah those politicians can't
do without people I remember I was
a kid in school and I remember uh you
know teacher this is some small stupid
example but like imagine the teacher
comes late to class and I was like yo I
remember literally being in like I must
have been like the third or fourth grade
or some
and I remember being like yo if we all
leave the class we can go to the recess
like yard and play and we can't get in
trouble cuz the teacher's not here the
teacher's late the teacher will get in
trouble like let's all go I get like one
or two kids might come with me but the
reality is like that's the same concept
on a big same concept yeah CU where
it's like oh I'm too afraid no no I
don't want to get in trouble well some
people get cuz some people go man I
leave I can't pay my bill I can't feed
my kids so they're they're compromised
so that it's like yeah don't go and then
there's some outliers who it's like I'm
going to go over over here I'm going be
fine I'm going P you know pay my own way
but even that concept that I was talking
about is is on a it's not even about
money it's not about school it's not
about they might trouble with their
parents because they don't have the same
belief so it's like you have to answer
to another it's all about fear it's
about fear being instilled everything's
fear driven brother everything and if
it's fear is instill the vaccine how
much money is they made off the vaccine
all that stuff it's all fear driven y
but you're like hold on this is killing
more people shouldn't we be more worried
about this like no no no but the vaccine
like yeah but more people dying cars and
suicide yeah but the I knew when it was
a problem when when I was talking to
these Health officials that were coming
to my gym and I said well what about the
airports they were like well that's
Federal jurisdiction that's not State
local jurisdiction so we don't know so I
was like so because it's a different
jurisdiction that this is not spreading
there the way that it's spreading here
yeah the because of the Juris you deci
jur exactly and that's when they were
like well we'll have to ask some people
and I was like well that's that's when I
knew I was like I can't even nobody can
explain it nobody can cuz there is no
explanation it's just we're just
deciding this because we say this and
that's when I was some double down on it
with his debate with s saved so many
people you killed millions of people I
like what facts do you have D yeah
people took their lives man they lost
their livelihoods they lost family
members like it's it made a lot of
people crazy too yeah it's weird but
that's my that's my thing is like what
so what can you do then right homeschool
keep finding a good fight try to you
don't change you keep finding you hope
more people jump on board I think that's
what's happening now I think a lot more
but then it's also just going to can
just get squandered by but if the major
meet out that you know send out all the
propaganda and they keep brainwashing
people you know you're just constantly
it's like a it's a it's a wave yeah it's
not a huge Wave It's a wave that just
doesn't stop yeah now some people can go
past that wave and get out there and hit
those big ass serves but some people
just they're like I can't they give up
like it's easier just go along with it
it's easier to go along with it people
just got to stop taking it easy Choice
man cuz all things like that are worth
having are difficult and hard to
hard to achieve and there's a lot of
people like that yeah you know
this fight I'm excited for man
this is the fight I don't know what to
expect because you got to remember KOB
hasn't fought in two years in all
reality probably shouldn't be even at a
title shot here he has one win over
mozal who older mozal shout out to mozal
love you but he is an older mazal hasn't
fought in two years he probably
shouldn't be here he's yeah he's got
crazy crazy endurance great
endurance yeah but I feel like in two
years remember Leon his last two fights
he fought Kamar twice that's kind of a
version of Kobe but better he he beat
him both times so he's been practicing
for a guy with good cardio good
wrestling decent boxing yeah for two
years so now he couldn't beat
kamaro and now he's supposed to beat
Leon who's been getting ready for Kamar
for two years and now you're fighting
the older Kobe hav't fought in two years
now I'm a Kobe fan I look at him
talking kid kid rock wants in so bad
he's like bu
light bro I was a a Co fan until Kobe
fan until um the Leon stuff yeah kit
covin doesn't Kobe coov Kobe kovit
Covington Kobe Kobe Kobe Kobe like Kobe
but Kobe is his name Kobe Kobe Kobe coov
Kobe hey you got it nice yeah have you
ever met him good I don't think so so
people that don't like him for all this
Antics I get all this especially the
Leon stuff but it would be like meeting
the Undertaker like whoa you don't live
in a coffin this is insane I don't like
this guy anymore like this is all a
stick it's all an act the nicest dude
most humble nicest kid I believe that
yeah it's just that he was like how do I
get attention yeah I believe that I can
tell I can tell about the the get up and
stuff he was wearing but he just went
too far I too far too much too much real
quick on the like there's like a bunch
of different Instagram things that
happened that said that when Colby and
Leon had the face to face Kobe said I
was in character I'm I'm in character
when he said that even though it's
you should never say like I don't give a
yeah said that when where was that
is that during a face off I don't know
if it's real he he'll let guys in on it
he'll it guys in on the St that he's
playing like when he him camar after the
fight he lost he goes you know I was
just selling the fight dog I'm just
playing the character selling the fight
and Kamar was like I get it and give him
big hug sold pay-per-views but with Leon
he's like dude I was just talking
about your dad dad sell fight he's like
nah bro that's where I draw the line
yeah yeah you got to know that you got
to know that listen this what this what
this what you do if you g to be that
type of guy you gotta talk to the guy
before to the Press confence before you
do it I say listen bro I'm an
Entertainer you know I'm going like
whatever I say out there you got to know
like I'm trying to sell fights I'm
making you money that's how it's tough
because if he was like won't hit the
same no no no but there's that but then
also he wants to get em he wants Leon
emotional but he actually wants that
advantage that's what he's doing what
he's doing come forward so I can take
you down get emotional try and knock me
out so I can take you down that's the
same way I'm going to talk to about
your dad and people are going to hate me
but I'm going to win the fight that's
all I care about that's the same way
Conor McGregor won that fight against
Jose Alo got him super emotional he
charged out bam 19 seconds whatever it
was that's what only thing I'm worried
about but uh uh I lowkey want um kic
covin to get his head kicked off though
good chance Leon's a Savage I'm gonna
get a drink I'm going to pee you guys
what are you drinking what are you
drinking dark pepper what you want no I
just want some water one you got another
one of these uh I'll look yeah check got
I got oh man so you come here often I
used to I here pretty often I here
pretty often I don't wear thongs though
oh you iongs no thongs for me man oh
you I I wouldn't want to see you in
no yeah man I don't have any stories
like that where I got robbed well you
that's good man I the weird thing the
weird thing about me is that uh I was
talking to my coach about that like that
weekend before and I didn't think it
would ever happen to me and the thing
was I was so drunk I didn't put my my
expensive stuff in a safe I was I had
put everything in I got I had another
bag like this and I put all my jewelry
in this and I had a bunch of stripper
wands from the last time I went to the
strip club in in Orange County and there
I put it all in my luggage and I locked
my luggage I said nobody's going to take
my luggage nobody's going to take your
whole luggage the took my whole
luggage oh was it a nice luggage
though no it wasn't a nice she must have
she must have opened that up and was
like holy she she didn't open it up
there no but when she got back it big
surprise no but she saw me wearing my
when she met me but she probably Lo
but she probably looked in the safe and
saw it was open cuz it was nothing in
there it was empty see but you said she
wasn't a she wasn't a prostitute she a
girl she was she wasn't a prostitute
just a girl she was a stripper she said
she told me kind like no no yeah I'm
sure listen she told me that she was a
stripper that she she wanted to I met
her I gave her I gave I I just gave her
my Instagram we exchange Instagram cuz I
thought she was hot I didn't know what
she was at first I thought she was a hot
girl at the bar talking to another dude
yeah remind you I am super drunk yeah
and and I asked that's your boyfriend
she said no no we just hanging out she
was with another girl I didn't I didn't
know she didn't dress like a hook or
nothing like that and then when I gave
her my I said oh let me your Instagram
we gave Instagram then me and my homeboy
she gave you her Instagram yeah me and
my that's how the police found her me
and me and my homeboy left and then she
hit me and she SL in my DMs and I was
like ego like yo this hot chick sliding
right there and talking to me and so and
then we was we was talking and then she
said she she's she's a stripper not a
hooker yeah okay and my homeboy was like
yeah yeah yeah let's let's let's get it
you know it was more like his idea as
well so I was like you said the police
found her so they got her yeah yeah they
got it she went to jail and everything
but she had already sold my she
went to a a music studio and sold my
damn I wonder who has your
right now the detectives know all some
some SoundCloud rapper or some
she sold my she so she sold
like I don't know what all she sold to
him but my watch is worth 110,000 she
sold it for
15,000 dummy she had no idea what she
damn they came up whoever bought that
yeah she had no idea what she had
what the
wow she did you dirty she did me
dirty whoever got that got a crazy deal
oh yeah if they if they if they go and
take it to AP or if they take it to in
word they can they can probably uh last
year my homeboy was telling me to sell
it I could have got 300,000
for it yeah watches were crazy last year
I could got three you have any other
watches that are nice like that uh not
not that nice I got like a um bling. uh
Rolex and two other watches but that was
my favorite watch damn did you dir and
what you had like a what kind of CH like
multiple chains I had a couple I had a
couple chains like a custom chain that
wasn't worth much but my bracelet my
bracelet was worth like $50,000 I had a
custom bracelet talking about that
hooker that robbed you she wasn't a
hooker bro that's a proen listen
listen I'm tell something she's a pro
but if she was a hooker she she never
would have been invited to my room well
and also she would she wouldn't have
given him the uh her Instagram she gave
me her Instagram she gave why can't
hookers have Instagram they don't give
Instagrams out like that yes they do why
not why can't hook her pretend as a
stripper how you know she could have
been she could have been that's what I'm
saying some strippers are also you know
they go the Boom Boom Room but she could
have been but she she didn't try to have
sex she didn't ask she didn't ask for no
sex she was coming there for what she
wanted man she got it yeah she got it
she she saw that change I told her I
gave the the detectives the um
thread cuz they thought I was
with hookers too I then I gave him the
thre was like damn you a freak dog
Tenacious D no they saw everything get
thiser at this gonation D I still
got I see I still got it I still got I
still got it I I got I still got the
thread in my phone jack yeah World Champ
I still got the third I still got the
third thread in my phone she she said
she was a stripper and she don't do sex
I'm like good I said I ain't no trick I
said I don't pay for no yeah that
that was that was established yeah I
don't pay for she's definitely not
a liar she do going to rob you I'm sure
she's ly she probably is a hooker but
she that's she draws the line there she
not going to lie understand she probably
she probably is a hooker oh she probably
hooked but that's not what she was doing
with me no that's what that's what I
want to make clear oh God I want I don't
buy I don't buy I don't like
buying water I why I don't like I don't
like buying that should be free I
drink t water I don't like buying
that should be free yep that's why I
drink T I should I should get paid for
my dick correct the Tenacious D The
Tenacious D I'm with you it's name of
the episode bro I heard my dick is tasty
oh they call it tasty D tasty tenacious
de and I got I got a pretty one I should
charge for it tell her that why didn't
you want to do the movie then no cuz I
don't want everybody saying how small it
is I ain't
all that it's it's cold in those
Studios too I've been in there that
is not hell yeah all that I
like I need 10 seconds man hey that's
the only stereotype that black people we
don't mind people think oh yeah black
man got the biggest yeah I go with that
stereotype that I pull the
that like a
Vape there's no long there's no long
girthy Vapes is you look
like come come Vape on this babe come
Vape on this come put this VAP that Vape
daddy baby yeah come put this brown Vape
in your mouth baby that's to there's no
big long black Vapes you know they're
all small so funny I'm joking y'all know
I'm j i a I ain't that small God damn it
it's all right if you're a small
one man there's nothing you can do about
it I know it's too late too late no no I
could be I could do like Ray J I can get
like a penis enlargement he has a penis
oh it's a machining by you said what
there's a machining by actually do that
you can do a surgery and get oh but you
didn't see the C Kardashian tape no yeah
did he he had a big winter I it looked
like he had surgery on it looked like
his scar was on there oh damn they cut
it they Fay it open they open they they
big they make it bigger CU I thought
when you have a uh a penis surgery they
cut like where your taints at just to
extend it like maybe an inch oh see iess
if you're hurting for an inch bro that
didn't that information yeah you looked
it
up and CH looked it up wait a second
looked up on fireing the kid oh what the
you looked into it I never do that
this kind of got hurt what
they the feeling in your dick and
now you can never feel sex again I
couldn't do it I couldn't do it I
couldn't if we're only talking one or
two inches I don't give a I'm good
but we're talking like 10 might look
into it wait wait wait 10 that be come
on you 10 you be have a 20 inch it'd be
fun with your friends
though just like what the up you know be
throwing that over your shoulder
yeah it' be
fun only fans are getting that only fans
bu what yeah what round you think this
ends in oh it's tough tough to call I
say third round
second look at he look nervous he's like
he's regretting he said I'm regretting
all this I
said oh they're not no they they can't
talk about his dad his dead dad and
expect don't throw kicks don't throw KCK
never throw that Charlie Brown kick and
look look he don't look like he get that
he he don't look like Jose Joo Leon's
coming forward though he look determined
Leon's a Sav are you going to throw that
jab Leon you go he I wish Co kicking
like that is he a CO he's a wrestler
yeah very good wrestler yeah Oregon
State look at look at Leon he cutting
off the cage he look focused he Look
Laser
focused God UFC at its highest level
nothing better yeah this is
great I don't know why damn trying Kobe
going forward applying the pressure he's
going to have to cut his hair off pretty
soon though Le have to sh do top is
tough it's very LeBron James is yeah
LeBron balling at 39 you should go to
Turkey my boy cowboy went there they
paid him they paid for your flight all
you got to do is post it I'm going to
get done they would eat definitely do it
they pay for everything I want to go get
done they say I'm not a candidate
though really you have enough the back
or what that's what they say they didn't
let me grow that for 10 10 days they
want me to grow for 10 days when they
get impatient I'm going to go do it do
it yeah I'm do it I'll connect you a
cowo hook you up at the same company
they want to do it to Brian County being
little about it why is he being a
I don't know cuz you got you going
have to shave it all off that's fine
whatever yeah just sucks for a little
bit you're here let me see your here uh
Rampage
nothing wrong with that they say you
don't have enough back here to give yeah
don't have yeah yeah I that's what they
said that that that that line up in the
front though is real that is stiff
it's a tattoo damn it looks good get
that uh SMP baby what's that SMP yeah
it's place in Vegas they tattoo that's
like what Bader did or what's the guy
the Boozer on the go to boozer's haircut
that's what you that's what you look
like right now hey you better not be
trolling me look look up
Boozer Carlos Boozer here just type in
Carlos Boozer here and you'll get
it that's
like that's not Rampage dude at all that
boy he did the Pittsburgh Steeler helmet
that boy got the bro I almost spit all
what the I almost spit all over
your Studio bro you wait why you
doing like that CH why you wait
take why you wait till I take a drink of
water to show that that's man
you've been flaming me this whole this
whole show man man that's up bro
he looks like guy like the guys on the
lava level Mario you jump on top of bro
you got to bro you got to know you got
to know that you got to know that
don't look right bro you got know
that's crazy that is atrocious bro
you got to know that don't look spr
that but you got to know you can
people can barely tell if I don't say
nothing no you're just that's why I mean
I know I know but it's how how did you
how did you know it's too it's too
perfect man you but i' I'd rather
have that than
whatever whatever train Rec was
before I can't wait you start losing
your bro tell me when I'm like that
you it's coming I see it right there in
your hairline no that's a cic I've had
that since I was a kid that's what
that's yeah me too I had one and it was
like this look at my bro I got
locks bro this funny you
40 right 40 thank you that's when I I
start going ball at 42 thank you you
going to go ball brother dag standing I
got to worry about it running my
eyebrows no that bro that's how it start
you I you I you might have a shorter
forehead I don't we're close are you
mixed with Cherokee no no
sir it must be my my Mongolian blood the
gang is Kong the gang is Kong heavy on
the they ain't doing it it's been
four minutes they ain't did feeling
each other out man man all that
Leon you you letting me down bro they
ain't did a goddamn thing oh there's a
little counter there by Leon Leon just
Co I tell you right now Kobe ain't G to
win this fight fighting like this on the
back foot not pressuring not going
forward not looking for take down Leon
Leon's waiting for him yeah he is but
he's going forward though usually Leon's
on that back foot counter punching but
now he's he's cting off the
cage they it's tough cuz Kobe really
doesn't knock dudes out they both
lose this round they'll give it to Leon
cuz he's the grasser huh ref put him on
the ground ref man
yeah it's a weird game plan by Colby
because you're you're basically giving
up you're starting 01 you you gave this
round away oh that was a great kick
there was a great kick that means The
Middle's open I don't like how col's
kicking Jim bring up DJ ked's terrible
beard that's another Boozer moment that
is hor Leon could get get get get
caught with like one of those crazy
punches though yeah he could be Kobe's
not really a knockout type of
dude you don't got The Knockout power no
it's not his thing
who you get his first round see that's
just for men right there look at that
yeah sadly the fans can't see it
but God damn yeah oh the fans can't see
boozers uh here
either no why why do the fans can't see
it I don't know since we're live it's
we're just kind of like it's a little
more touchy we're just worried why with
really showing pictures from Google we
can we can figure it out for the next
episode damn ain't that a I
thought they were able to see all our
no yeah damn chin no it's it's not
not a tight man damn what the
we're just worried we're going to get
like if we show something or play a
video FL yeah and then videos I get but
picture what's this this on YouTube yeah
they they tripping like they oh YouTube
super that's why I as if I can cuss cuz
I was I wasn't sure YouTube is not on
our team as far they're on us like crazy
so what about that um that new site yeah
how how they it's kind of it's too
political like for what I do with the
fighting and the the comedy it's tough
cuz it's a political fan base I don't
know I mean now like Tucker Carlson's on
there they threw him at bag they throw
your boy a bag I'll jump on over there
man all right who you think who you
think won the first round oh won nothing
Leon I Kobe he just gave away a round
and he didn't really learn much either
this boring cuz he didn't attempt
any takedowns or nothing he's he going
to get ready to take him down he goingon
to get ready to go for the shot I he has
to I see him setting it up
he's doing a pump fake Brad's eating the
out of CH yeah uh I see what he's
doing this why Liam's not doing much cuz
Leon thinks that he's going to try to
get him to engage so he can go for the
shot yep and he's being smart about it
yeah that's why that's a good counter
there by Kobe but Coe has to get Leon
going backwards even though Leon's a
great counter Striker but like why not
shoot when he's coming forward your goal
he got clipped there your goal can't be
to out strike Leon Edwards that could
there's no way you did a twoe
camp and the idea is to out strike the
best Striker at the welterweight
division he hasn't Fen two years no bro
his last one was
mozol how how did the mazal go he beat
the brvs off mazal there's like two 108
rounds is mazal retired now uh yeah um
I'm sure he get news soon I like mazal
though love mazal it's my
boy this is such a terrible game plan by
Colby now he's not with at anymore he's
running running his own Camp so it could
be that his coach is like yeah just out
strike him like it's a great
idea where's he from where's kid from
he's from Oregon but he fights out of
Florida and he was at ATT and then uh
there was an issue with him and Po and
him in
mosal damn he's actually from California
went to school at Oregon State where the
is a
clovis I've never heard of clov
California it's probably like a one
horse Town yeah where's Clovis you know
he look like he from a one horse town is
that near
Fresno it's oh it's middle middle
California you born and rais here San
Francisco
yeah that says a lot about San Francisco
is tough man tough real tough tough area
your brother ever drive up there in his
van yeah s Fran yeah if this the mom oh
your mom's still up there yeah she's
still live there so it's near Fresno oh
you're right all well you was right we
from up there from California NorCal too
you from NorCal yeah that's the bay yeah
that's not considered NorCal right
Clovis is definitely not the bay oh but
you if San Francis that is theay San
Francisco Bay anything past San
Francisco noral Northern California yeah
I went to college in northcal yeah
where'd you go lasson what the did
you just make up a school no it's a
junior college oh you lasso yeah I went
the last it's like the middle of nowhere
middle nowhere that's Town that's no l
State Tag what the that town so
that town so small the big thing was
when Richard Simmons came to the Walmart
that would be lit he came there back in
the 80s or whatever it was the 90s I'm
not that old
man God damn it was the late 90s at that
probably like
99 late 9 almost 2000 this
said the 80s the 80s he hey
hey have y hey have y'all 5 years older
listen I just got questions you Ain
clown him not one time since he been
here you scared of him but you ain't
scared of
me you know cuz you know I ain't going
to fight I just got questions bro I
question about his brother in the van
that's not clowning no no no no you
didn't clown him at all there's no
clowning man you clowned his brother a
little bit you didn't clown him at all
what you been setting him up though you
set him up yeah you set me up you set me
up with these I can't believe I can't
believe you I didn't know man it's
Richard simm he was popular in the
80s right yeah but did he die I don't
know if he died he died right let me see
or am I thinking of PeeWee Herman PE
Herman definely died yeah but I'm pretty
sure Rich Sherman's died Richard Simmons
right yeah uh no he's still alive I was
75 years old oh God damn you think he's
still working out with he tried picking
me up first day I moved to LA he
probably still working out pulled up in
a Land Rover was like hey are you
serious swear out my life swear to God I
believe it real talk I was like damn
that's Richard Simmons I we we jumped in
had a good time no just kidding I was
like what the and I ran the other
way real talk he tried to pick you up
swear on my life swear on my kids he
asked you for your phone number no he's
just like hey where you going I I I was
new to La I was walking down weo MH I
was at a a corn fresh corn Grill came
out of there you got be making I swear
have got I was in some short jean shorts
why you was in some UFC I because I like
the party and I was I ate my meal I was
walking out on uh West Hollywood and he
tried picking me up in a Land Rover West
Hollywood west I I didn't know that was
like there's rainbows everywhere this
you walking down West holwood some booty
shorts on yeah and you surprised that
rich Sim trying to pick you up I was in
the
UFC y nothing's happening well Kobe's
he's not a great Striker and he's
decided to make this a striking contest
like wrestle bro Trump's going to be so
Trump's going to hit him you think he
just don't know how to get in there or
what he hasn't even attempted who knows
so he's down two nothing now his coach
are like hey bro you're not here to
slap box I'm such a big fan of
trump I I wonder if if if uh Leon win
Will trump put the bet on him no not a
chance CA Trump Is So Pro American yes
you think Trump's gonna win I hope he
wins Trump loves this country who else
is gonna win this the other Biden can't
run no no there a new kid I've been
seeing on there he's he looks like he's
Indian Indian oh you talking about r v
yeah he he seem like he knows a lot he
has no background in politics though not
that you need it but he Donal Trump
didn't but he look he telling the truth
and he knows it sounds like he knows
what you're talking about I don't know
anything about politics there's no one
that's going to be Trump they just got
to like he's so high up in the Democrat
it's a oneman race but they're just
going to try and stop it he is so hated
he is so hated but listen I think a lot
more people see that he was telling the
truth about the stuff he was saying
agree and I think a lot more people are
coming back to liking him but he's still
so hated I don't know why and the
Democrats are throwing everything hoping
something sticks and gets him jail but
dude he could still be voted in as
president and then uh get himself out of
prison he oh
tried that was a yeah Kobe looks a
little old I bet you co if Kobe loses I
don't see him uh going back down the
queue and fighting for the like young
prospects I bet retires Kobe is getting
his ass kick keep kicking that leg look
at that leg you see it getting R there
you go these guys are talking about the
same thing baffling performance by
Kobe's just striking with Leon Edwards
now he might be older the knes aren't
the same so he can't he can't shoot the
taked down yeah he's not setting it up
good oh he should have shot after those
too
yeah would you get a king-sized bag of
those chips or dude I'm sorry they're so
good I didn't think you it's been it's
been 30 minutes of
chewing he's destroying those things
they are tasty they're so good my coach
said it's better to just fast than eat
well your coach takes steroids
so he Li to you about you believe it
just like it is what it is it is what it
is he's still in great shape looks
awesome my coach is not on steroids yeah
he's not if he says he's not I believe I
don't steroid why would anyone lie about
that ever yeah I I why would he have to
lie about it though he's he's not like
in a public ey he's not famous or
nothing like that he don't care yeah
he's not trying to be on Instagram no he
just he just you know you know why he
got you know why he got so many
followers cuz he's Persian people don't
know that he looks white he's Persian oh
yeah he looks white as yeah he's
Persian so be though so he got a lot of
he got a lot of Persian followers and
stuff like that he he does he speaks for
farsy and so he he got a lot of Persian
people that follow him and stuff like
Persians are dope he speaks fary on the
internet sometimes oh that's cool you
don't see a lot of that let's go
something man Fu goes oh oh oh he gots
his legs together ah he's too
high oh damn oh oh oh nope
that was a bad idea now he's going to
take him down yeah oh he got him down
now that was a bad idea he looked at his
he looked at his corner like third yeah
Kobe has why not do this in the first
round Kobe you've given up two rounds
playing grab ass it was made a mistake
yeah he like looked like he almost had
it look like he going to go for an arm
bar or something get up from this it's
going to be tough with Kobe on top of
you but he's pretty good getting up oh
oh he
got so fast Kobe in trouble now yeah oh
look at him shooting him shoo what is
going what why he do that Kobe took down
Usman yeah Kobe's takedown is not bad
look he's going to take him down look at
this look at that look at that he took
down Usman and he took down Kobe now
that boy wrestle wow I'm impressed yeah
I'm impressed he's going for that oh he
got him how impressive is that got taken
down got up shot back in got him down
now he's about to kick him in the
face Kobe's in trouble that that takeown
was the ego thing yes that's that's all
it was yeah all he was like oh really
check this
out Kobe's like damn I took him down he
got up then he took me down I'm now I
got I'm his mind is yep yeah
that's he's in a little bit of trouble
now look he got switched stances I I
kick the other leg when he he he's back
kick that leg the leg is back every time
he kick that leg he switch stance I
don't see if Leon wants to get a bunch
of fans he should knock Kobe out and
then flip Trump
off and then be like Bradley stop eating
the mic oh dude it's not that bad I'm
back away from it right hey if Leon flip
off the the world's greatest president
I'mma stop being a fan of him yeah yeah
yeah I get
it Kobe's forc a if I told you Kobe's
forc a strike with Leon in the third
round there's no way you'd bet on Kobe
it's a
disaster who was favorite to bet on Leon
was pretty heavily favorite I mean
twoyear layoff man Kid Rock looks so
sad Kid Rock remember Kid Rock blew up
the Bud Light with a gun and then like a
week later drinking Bud Light he's like
yeah it is what it is I don't follow a
Kid Rock he does like cruise ships bro
one time right after my fight with with
with
um Forest Griffin like shortly after
that uh I went home to Memphis and one
of my old old high school wrestling
buddies like yeah I got some Kid Rock um
concert tickets for you me and my cousin
went and I thought Kid Rock was still
kid rocks that type of rap stuff and I
went country yeah and I me and my cousin
only two black people there yeah man
that's a that you're in trumpville it's
like when I go to Monster Jam oh my God
bro I left I I left in one woman said I
never thought you would go down you know
with the southern accent in my hometown
yeah I like what you talking about I try
to make a joke what you talking about I
don't go down she said oh yeah you went
down against Forest like Dam I
didn't even go down he he won by
decision the you talking about I
said I'm out I'm out of here I'm sure
the Kid Rock concert attracts some weird
people that's like Monster Jam it's just
like a warlock calling yeah I stopped
being a fan of him when I found out that
he's doing country I'm like that's not
my my genre oh I love when he's like my
name is
kid Kid Rock music used to be fir was
great didn't he because he in Detroit
right he came up uh with I don't know
where he's he's from Detroit I didn't
know that I didn't know where he's from
has he ice y why the ice though what's
that really going to do the ice it it
lowers your temperature I think yeah
chill calms you down temperat that much
yeah
yeah cuz from Michigan he's from
Michigan you can Detroit hipop you
haven't had that one fight yet have you
well you you should hey let's let's do
this let's do this let us handpick him
an opponent I'm down and we just put it
on YouTube live or something like
that he wants a he wants a bag though he
wants a bag wa what this is like amateur
like you don't get for amateur get
it first fight some these YouTubers do
though that's what he wants well where
well he know how to make money from it
yeah you don't think we could you should
have you should have a warm-up
fight it's not as cool
want k for a whole bunch of people ain't
cool either yeah but if you're going to
do it you want to get paid if you're get
be you already a Millionaire's money
everything exactly that's the
point like why just do it then you need
be more like your brother right now man
yeah okay go live in a van okay your
brother would fight somebody for no
money in a
van different circumstance bro you you
you the man you can make you can make
money fight somebody else that that
never had a fight before both of you
guys make money together I'm trying to
think it'd be good for him though
somebody heavyweight has to be but they
have to be have like a big fall like he
has a like Bradley's pretty famous I
know but he can get somebody else that
want to try got a big following they
never fought before damn that was a good
that was a good shot I know is he going
to get out of it Leon oh does he have a
guilty he need to face him and get the
double under hooks now
yep oh look he has a front guil oh it's
tight oh it's tight oh he could have
break his own neck he could have broke
his own neck he could have broke
his he's fight
nasty
damn that was impressive that was
impressive he could have broke his own
neck God if you're Kobe though it's like
you've tried everything man yeah like
where do you go from here I I wouldn't I
wouldn't be surprised if he retires
tonight I don't see him going down back
in the queue and trying to I mean even
just in this fight where do you go in
the rest of his fight couldn't take I'd
be relentless with the takedowns cuz
he's just going to get look at his body
he's get picked apart say outside look
at his leg look at his body like he's
getting eaten alive how you get a
tighter shot after two years anyway two
years that's what people are saying it's
like he shouldn't been here but you know
it's a WWE UFC mix he's chopping him
down but this is the fourth round though
Leon should have been chopping their leg
a little bit more
though you try to hit him with the Jake
Paul terrible gameplay when you're
forced to strike with Leon Edwards
especially after you made fun of his
dead dad awful awful night for
Kobe now he just looks stupid yeah now
he looks
ridiculous but I tell you what I would I
would take some of my hatred back if
Leon's dad was really like trafficking
and doing all that crazy stuff though
according to kobby he was alleged that's
allegedly we don't know either we need
to we need to you know there's no
facts that was if they want to make this
fight exciting do uh in the middle of
the fight check in with Trump see what
he thinks of the fight check with
be what do you guys thinking who you
have winning how dope with that you got
all these celebrities there you got
Donald Trump there Trump what do you
how's Kobe looking things and pull it
out what do you like so far he's doing
excellent he's doing great he's doing
excellent you're like no he's not hey
you think if Trump get back in office
will he still come to the UFC fights
yeah and Dana are close yeah
yeah but he got to have like 100 Secret
Service with him and like that he
has to have it now you know how many
people want to kill anyway you get it
for like 20 years after you retire I
know you get it for life oh that's right
I think life
yeah and there's a bunch of I remember
when we played tnm President Bush showed
up when I was in college I was at CU we
played at T&M I was like what is all
this Secret Service it was all for
President Bush there was n kit hey if
you was a secret servant for for Trump
don't say servant service service
service Serv is what they are they are
that's a secret servant yeah
secret if you you a secret servant for
um for Trump trump would you take a
bullet for him oh that's my job so you
do that's my job yeah dog you got to do
it you kind of got to that's like saying
hooker like I'll do it but I don't suck
dicks like whoa whoa hey why you go
there though you're in the wrong
business girl I think I think hookers
they like sucking dick that's why they
in that job yeah they probably prefer
that than the whole get
down damn bro Dam his leg is tore up
this just damn man hey do you think you
finish that bag for the fifth round I'm
trying yeah I know you are I know you
are I know you
are damn he's he's man he's just Bing
him oh he's going be some trouble oh
made a mistake there oh get got his back
45 seconds left
though W he's Whispering is here about
his dad right now damn would that be
messed up oh yeah that' be messed up
what could you have that Native American
tattoo on him though which one the
feather on his freaking C he over oh
oh KOB takedown offense is filthy man
he's just made some errors in in the
transitions where he keeps ending up on
bottom it's strange Trump has no clue
what he's watching right now I mean not
a lot has
happen take a few take Downs what if
Dana tell the judges to get this fight
to co so Donald Trump can get in there
no well I heard Trump wanted to walk
Kobe out but Danel was like uhuh why I
don't know how you hearing all this
stuff yeah who where you hear that from
I hang out certain water coolers man
water cooler around water you Dana still
cool huh yeah I'm cool with you text you
don't text you text him cool no I don't
think he likes me but I'm cool with him
oh okay I don't know I I have nothing
have you ever asked him to be on on your
podcast
never never I I asked my manager to ask
him once a week I'm surprised he
wouldn't come on yours do you guys have
a good relationship I don't think so
why we we stopped having a good
relationship when I did the 18
movie because you wanted to do the movie
and he wanted you to fight yeah that
just my luck the movie came right when I
was supposed to fight Rashard I've been
working on that movie for at that time
probably like good five years and but
you got understand Dana is businessman's
like no dog like you you got a contract
obligation you decide to do this fight
yeah you fighter you movie star you know
what saying he needs to play ball cuz
it's like all right well if I do this
movie I get more famous sells more
pay-per-views for you so you're going
make more money if you just give me this
time right he wasn't thinking but he
doesn't it's his way of the highway yeah
what what saved me is I didn't sign a
boutle agreement oh type move yeah he
signed that boutle agreement you just I
I I didn't sign I didn't it was just it
just happened the battle agreement
wasn't there yet oh good for
you so it went the relationship went
South after that yeah the relationship
went South mine went South when I
started talking about the rebok
deal I'm you talk the about that re
rebok me over too so yeah me too
I'm the one that brought that deal and
they just everything I didn't make a one
red Cent yeah I went hard in the pain on
it Dana should have just Dana should
have gave me some of that money though
he should gave me something just smooth
things over yeah me too he just hijacked
my whole sponsor yeah me too all my stff
yeah you lost a lot of money cuz
because yeah I'm glad it happened though
it forced me to get into podcast and
standup so he actually helped me out I I
have no ill will towards him at
all which which was you say your stand
up is better in the cage or on the
stage oh good question I like the way
you phrase that yeah me too man you're a
poet dog definitely on
stage I've been doing standup comedy as
long as I've been doing punch and now
almost nine years
I I want to do it but I don't have the
balls to you'd be so good at it
get over
that they take a lot of balls to stand
in front of people and try to make them
land yeah that's tough
man I ra go in some tight ass shorts to
get my ass kick in front of millions of
people not me
that you know I saw I went to laugh
factor I saw chrisa he was so surprised
guest Chris monster do he was moner it
was so weird how you could see how the
room just throw some punches throw some
punches before him some people after
when he wasn't
wrestling like the energy nuts thr some
punches he he he want to submit him no
that be nuts if you if you bet uh Leon
Edwards via submission yeah you can bet
that like how yeah yeah on DraftKings
you using prom coach big one you with
DraftKings yep they take good care of
you yep tell them about your them for
years tell them about your black friend
I'm sure they'd be down for your pod
could you you do the Pod with who with
um bear I've never met him I've heard
good things though I tell you that I
heard good things about him he's a good
dude bro my buddy what's up with some
chains dog all right I like chains you
like chains yeah man all right we'll
hook you up thanks
D damn what's he got a he oh he has a
triangle oh now he has an AR and there's
a lot of time left oh he got out of
it what's more likely Leon finishes with
a triangle or Bradley finishes that bag
of chips
uh your lips are
red Bradley for sure I ain't going to
finish the chips to be honest are you g
to fast tomorrow now you ate all this no
I'm eat some more tonight hell yeah do
you ever fast yeah every day how many
hours um I normally eat around like 2
2:30 3:00 I stop eating around like
10:00 I fast from 7 to 2 p.m. 700 p.m.
to 2 p.m. yeah 10 to 3: I do it every
day I don't eat breakfast I don't eat
the so I quit I eat dinner at 7:00 yeah
and then I don't eat again till 2:00
p.m. oh okay the next day oh that's good
10 to 3 fasting works man yeah that's
why I got my whole life yeah you've been
doing your whole life my whole life yeah
it ages you backwards
too yeah you do look younger yeah man
yeah you look I mean you lost some
weight too but you look a lot better
than last time oh yeah I was I was
bad that time thank yeah yeah last time
you were sweating and huh you were
sweating yeah you were sweating like you
had one of them you know ones coming
like right here man chin you going to
let you going to let them keep doing me
like this bro well Chin's a Bonafide
alcoholic don't look at him CH chin be
drink again all the time all day yeah
damn chin got liver problems we'll
do a show at 9:00 a.m. I'm like chin
have you had a whiskey he's like yep
it I used to be right there with
him and then I got my ass together that
was one of my favorite times you and me
you yeah me and you were drinking
buddies man that's a problem it is you
going to
stop of course yeah you think you are
going to stop Jen yeah when well so I
got my blood test back and it's it's
fine so I started drinking more because
my blood cells is fine chin sounds like
a real attic right now that's crazy
yeah has it affected your life at all
Chen I mean what do you think yeah I'm
I'm I'm just trying to guide you to the
light here it's like it's like grandage
trying to guide me into Flat Earth I
ain't trying to guide you into Flat
Earth no but you're you're showing me
the ways that's what I'm doing with
children I'll just tell you what I
believed in I know and I dig it I'm not
trying I'm listening I'm a like it I'm
not trying to push that on anybody like
people can believe in whatever they want
emergency Landings yeah I'm going to
look that up tonight so he's on top
right now he's he just doing work yeah
he won one round maybe because the I
guess if he ends it might they'll give
him this round but the majority of the
fight like Leon was doing really well
early in this round so I guess you give
it to
him like why all that now why you why
come on K put oh that's the fight that's
the fight I know Kobe definitely didn't
win that fight he said give me the belt
definitely not Happ he lost four to one
yeah not the best fight he got a little
better at the end there but Kobe was
gave up three
rounds at Le I mean for sure too so I'd
say 4-1
Leon that guy's Beard's big yeah
4-1
well that dude's man BN is tight damn
yeah that's
tough 4-1 four 4 one for sure I mean and
in a robbery it'd be
3-2 hey been shot the next title
shot shot just looks unfreaking beatable
man but Leon Edwards monster I think I
think Wonder Boy could have beat him he
just did he just did something stupid he
just it's tough on the ground man sh
cat's Relentless yeah why why you go to
the ground with him you got I know I'm
I'm curious how sh cot would do against
Leon with that that taked down defense
they the same way day yeah shop cot was
third on there this was close is that
who's next dude I've never seen imag
that was crazy as never seen
somebody get out of Muhammad probably
deserves it Muhammad deserves the next
title shot he was the actually the
alternative for this fight yeah he waigh
in and still England got two champs they
got Aspen and Leon Edward
you think um Patty the bad will ever be
a
champ tough with his
striking he probably hope so his
striking is tough man and his
wrestling's not good enough to dominate
especially at 55 what's he gonna do
against uh
magedov tough bro what would he do
against Justin gagei Dustin
po Chandler gamrot darush he
the toughest yeah
Ben was St Denise o that guy's so
scary and what's he ranked
12 how many rounds they give him chin do
we
know is he G get on there talk he talk
oh he
said oh they're talking crap to
Kobe yeah his team is Kobe must have
said something
there's no way Kobe there's no argument
he won that I wish I could hear
Rogan
damn you can't turn on even for a
second n turn off a tiny little bit
there you go here 49 46 49 46 49 46 yeah
that's
fair I gotta go back and watch his
interview yeah unfortunately
yeah Joe's so focused damn they had they
had Patty 3027 across the
board
actually ptoa pitched a shut out
basically 50
45 not the great fights like on paper
but not a great
card yeah not a great card not a great
main card that coach is
upset
can you hear it case
no h it's all right we don't to risk
it who's he calling out uh I mean bah
muhamed's probably next unless they want
to give it to shot which would screwed
Bal over but they should probably give
it to Bal he deserves it but I could see
them edging it to shot which is messed
up it'd be interesting if Ian Gary found
this card had a highlight real head kick
knockout then do shop cot Ian
Gary then B muhamad
Leon it's a long interview
huh it's probably I like nothing
happened in that fight not a great fight
I mean Leon Leon looked good the problem
was Co Kobe's game plan was just
atrocious you you give up two rounds a
championship fight stand going back
backwards when you're a pressure
Grappler fighter it's insane give up two
rounds
yeah they talking a lot yeah that
was that easy night in the office for
Leon I would assume Kobe retires I don't
know he's going go back in the queue
like if they want to discipline Kobe
they give him shovot that'd be a tough
fight for Kobe shovot why would they
want to discipline him though or just
you know how it is when a guy's on his
way out they're like wait before you
leave let's take all your fans here's
the Young Lion like they did with Patty
P yeah why they why they do that they
always with everyone they did with
everyone except for me they they gave me
um
texara Glover yeah that was my last
fight in UFC it's a big fight oh damn
they're interviewing
Colby damn you think it's an actor you
see that tattoo on his
chest he's Pro American super
am
I want to know what the he's
probably saying I won that fight easily
won that
fight I think but Kobe Kobe's three out
of his last four it'd be tough he's
goingon to have to jump way back in the
queue we give him shop cot next he lost
three of his last four yeah cuz he suck
look at Donald that
smile he must have mentioned Donald what
did Donald and Chris Rock talk about I
Kid Rock what do they what are those
combos like the blow in hookers yeah
those boys get wild they Vegas tonight
too Trump has his hotel there I thought
you said it was in Toronto no the the uh
DDP vers uh Sean Strickland's in Toronto
okay it is is Vegas yeah yeah Trump
getting Wild tonight with Kid Rock and
Colby by the way so um sonaz and Georgie
sent this apparently Sean Strickland and
DDP got in a fight yeah in the stands or
oh yeah oh damn and Sean whing on
him oh wait a
second
damn it's Instagram so I have to let it
go guys let's see look at him go Sean's
in the white uh T of
course there's DDP right here and by the
way the fans can't see this so kind of
sucks but here we go Sean's like wailing
on someone whing on elbows and damn
them boys scrapping
yeah I wonder what they fighting about
they they supposed to fight next they're
going to fight why would they put them
so close together though that's so
stupid if that's the case yeah well the
UFC is like we don't like this drama but
also tell us you don't like this drama
without telling us you don't like this
drama they put them next to each other
for a reason they know that's going to
happen they hate each other it's a WWE
yeah that's all they're do well
that's all the UFC is they just take a
page out of Vince McMahon's book that's
all they're doing did you f the chips no
damn I felt bad so I stopped but thanks
man I'm going eat him when as soon as we
end this I'm poor Bal Mohamed give him
the goddamn title shot he's wion 10 10
in a
row Leon's won 13 good luck catching Jon
Jones yeah Jones blew his uh out towards
CH a bad injury or pack or something
yeah it's
pack oh Leon's on a 13 win streak he's a
problem damn UFC running a little light
for the next few
weeks that's Strickland d card's good
yeah I'm doing a fight campaign with
Rogan for
thatn of fight nights yeah I'm going
Austin bunch of fight nights so what's
going to happen to Strickland and DDP
for fighting no nothing no they might
get
[Laughter]
bonuses is that it case yeah well fellas
Rampage you're the best brother you
deliver every time oh thank you thank
you for having me you're looking great
man whatever you're doing keep it up
shout out to your trainer who's not on
steroids 100% not still a dig no he's
not no I'm saying he's not Brad said he
is honest I believe him why not at 40
years old 42 years old yeah but you
think he's on steroids why not to be
that shred at 42 I see why you have
skeptical hippo eyes I'm saying I've
seen fre I thought steroids like make
you like big and balloon and not
shredded they make you everything that's
how I know he's on steroids now well no
it's not how I know but he's dried
out yeah he walks around at 5% body fat
all year Al you think Sarah just make
you big and puffy that's what I thought
yeah no he can take wind straw certain
things that shred you get those veins
nice but again he could be he could be a
genic I'm going give the benefit of the
doubt he he might be a freak there's
guys like that but why but why would he
lie to me though why not but I'm saying
we why why' that hooker lie to you I
know why she lied cuz she trying to rob
me she trying to rip me off fair point
but why would he why why would he why
would he lie to me though I yeah I don't
know
dude maybe he's not am I am I a Gable
person no
I'm telling there I know real freaks who
are not that shredded but they close I
think people lie about that stuff
because then it makes their work look
then your assumption to be like you know
so much cuz you're not doing this thing
that people go which isn't true cuz he
probably works his ass off super
disciplined whether he's on steroids and
people know I keep it real cuz I I you
know if if I if honestly I wouldn't tell
my my friends business but I wouldn't be
here like defending some like I don't
think he is Bradley does is what it is
yeah he told me he he used to it
everybody think he is yeah I bet he's
used and he don't care he laughs he
laughs he looks great especially at that
age of well what working for youth
that's all that matters I don't give who
cares if he's doing math and I'm and I'm
natural I haven't been yeah I haven't
been taking anything and he actually got
me off testosterone well I hope I hope
you get that fight with Lennox Lewis man
I think I think the fight with uh
Shannon Briggs is meant to be first y
but then what I want to do is I want to
get the like if they're going to do a
Legends belt over there r i want that
belt that'd be dope I hope you get it
it's the old man belt and Bradley two
pods mommy daddy raw talk two pods I'm
done do pods twice a week or once a week
for both pods Bradley Martin on
Instagram yeah I love you guys as far as
standup goes I am in uh Nashville in
Austin end of January and uh new
Toontown comes out next week it's all
about the Ford Lightning so stay tuned
that's on Toontown uh YouTube that's it
kids love you guys see you next
week awesome